Thank you.
Hi, Andrew. We're going to... Oh, hi, Tender. Oh, good. People are showing up. It's going to be a couple minutes while we get everything together. My co-host should be around. And I just like to wait for a few people to... Well, not... You guys are people enough, obviously, but... So I don't have to repeat myself more than the eight times I already do.
Hi, Sal.
Morgan's finishing his dinner. He'll be along with some TRB insights into disclosure and the... I don't know, the different information that remote viewers get.
Just going to be a couple minutes while we square up here.
You know, while we're waiting, I'd like to make a little plug for something that I'm not selling, nor do I receive any money for.
At this time, I don't think it's appropriate to elaborate more on this subject other than to say, if your doctor is okay with the idea of you taking apple pectin fiber,
why wouldn't you take apple pectin fiber?
Now, didn't they always say an apple a day keeps the doctor away?
And maybe a lot of that goodness that's in that apple is in apple pectin fiber.
So I would always tell anyone that I was friends with, hey, if you can afford it, it's a big container for $20.
If you can afford the $20, and not everyone can in this economy, God knows.
There's no judgment there.
But if you can, why not take apple pectin fiber?
It detoxes the body, right?
That's what they say.
That's what people say.
I'm not a medical doctor.
It detoxes the body.
It supposedly lessens the chance at the onset of chronic diseases.
It's good for your liver.
It's good for your blood sugar.
For someone like me, it's good for losing weight.
But, you know, in our modern world, there are a lot of strange pollutants that we might encounter in our day-to-day lives.
And something like apple pectin fiber can help your body detox.
This is what they say, hypothetically, could help your body detox those pollutants.
They've even given it to children in the Ukraine because they still have environmental contamination from Chernobyl in the Ukraine.
So they give the children in the Ukraine, as an experiment, they gave some apple pectin, and some of them, they didn't give any apple pectin.
And the problem is there's still stuff in some of the food.
So even after they finally got them clean food, they said, okay, you all have clean food now, but we're going to give some of you apple pectin, too.
And they found a significant reduction in some of that stuff from Chernobyl that was still in the soil years later, right?
Because the topic of this discussion is not nuclear stuff, but just, you know, nuclear particles, right?
Radioactive particles are different from radiation.
I know everyone here is going to know this, but someone listening might not know this, right?
So who listens later?
So, you know, radiation, it's a ray, it's a point in a wave, it's a, you know, it has an effect on you, and then it's gone.
But when you ingest or inhale, say, if you were in Chernobyl and you were ingesting or inhaling radioactive particles, those particles could hang around in your body for a long time, and they would release radiation that whole time, right?
So that's why, like, people who are in Hiroshima or Nagasaki or people who are within the zone of the Chernobyl zone have so many long-term health problems because they have those particles in their body.
And when some of those kids were given apple pectin fiber, they started to, they started to, their body started to clear some of those particles, right?
Like, not perfect for them, but they saw immediate improvement.
Now, that, you know, why would any of us in the U.S. have to worry about something like that?
But, you know, just look at all the health benefits associated with apple pectin fiber, and that's what I always recommend to people.
And why not, you know?
Why not take it?
I'm going to try to bring Morgan up to speak or co-host and or, depending on what the algorithm is going to allow us to do now.
Because the algorithm really defines, you know, the algorithm really restrains us and defines what we're able to do in these spaces.
Sometimes it'll allow people to speak, sometimes it won't.
Sometimes it'll allow people to co-host, sometimes it won't.
I'm not saying this is a problem unique to me, but my technological issues probably make it a worse problem for me than other people.
Morgan, let me know if and when you get the invitations and et cetera.
So, since he's here and he's going to pop up in a minute, I might as well just get started.
And anyone who wants to come up and talk is welcome to come up and talk.
We don't do this like me talking for two hours and no one else talking because that's what I prefer.
We do it because usually we're talking about subjects that people might not know a lot about and they don't feel comfortable talking about them.
But people are always welcome to come up and talk.
I appreciate it when that happens.
While Morgan is, until we get Morgan up,
I can say that before this disclosure thing happened, I had a, not a phone call, a series of voicemails with another remote viewer,
whom I would just assume leave anonymous at this time,
on a subject related to, why is it mute everyone?
Okay, you're up.
Good.
Hey, Shane.
So, yeah, I had a conversation prior to the disclosure event with a remote viewer,
who I'll leave anonymous at this time, through these voicemails.
And we discussed, well, you're up here, Morgan, and now you're down there.
I think you're going to come back up again, but nope, we're going to drop and then sign on again.
Okay.
See, this is what we have to do because we have serious boomer energy.
Neither one of us are boomers and Morgan is younger than I am, but we have boomer energy.
That's just a fact.
No offense, dude.
So, released around technology.
So, yeah, he was doing some work and, you know, the conclusion he's come to,
he's an experienced remote viewer, not like Morgan, but he's got some experience.
His conclusion is that a lot of the cryptids that people are encountering are something like the, quote,
interdimensional, extraterrestrial that people are trying to, or people are kind of obsessed with in UFOX right now.
So, uh, gin, right?
Everyone likes to, um, sort of revert back to that, the gin concept for some reason, which is strange for me because it wasn't a big thing in the past,
but I guess it is now.
Plasma lifeforms.
I don't know if either one of those is applicable, right?
Gin are made out of fire and smoke.
And, um, you know, plasma, plasma lifeform, lifeforms with the orbs.
Um, I don't know if what my friend was saying, um, was either one of those.
But there is something involved, something assuming a form, something, um, not from this reality, uh, summoned or brought into being,
or, um, the result of, of, of some kind of, uh, magical ritual or some sort of technological, um, capability.
What was interesting about that is, and this is something that's come up in, uh, books on the subject.
Uh, years ago, I remember reading some books on the subject where you'll have these cryptid events and you'll have extraterrestrials or,
okay, that's it.
That's, uh, so I don't know that for a fact.
You'll have beings in flying saucer type vehicles or that appear to be in flying saucer type vehicles observing the event.
And, and, and according to some RV data, not from Morgan, um, enjoying it, getting sort of a kick out of,
uh, having a rampaging Bigfoot or pterodactyl or something that really gives people, um,
an ontological shock.
So, um, I'm not certain if this individual, cause we only, we spoke briefly, if he is, has determined that he believes that whatever's in those saucers is responsible for the, um, cryptid appearances, or if it, uh, is aware of them and, and, and observes them just out of like, uh, opportunity.
But that is something that has been, uh, if you go back to the book, I always recommend, uh, The Gods of Eden by William Bramley, which is, I think, where everyone should start, um, when they get involved in, um, the topic of UFOs.
They would often, um, they would often, in the past have, um, religious, um, themed experiences or cryptid type experiences and then there would be a, some sort of vehicle or what might be a vehicle in the sky observing the experiences.
So this is not something that's like new, um, he perceived it in some sessions, but it's definitely not a new thing to have that happen.
Hey, Morgan, what's going on, dude?
Uh, are we failing to, to bring you up for some strange reason?
Uh, I don't know.
Can you hear me?
Oh, there you are.
No, you're there.
Oh, shit.
No, I'm sorry.
My screen was frozen.
Like I was going on.
Cause I thought you hadn't gotten up yet.
I wasn't trying to like, just keep rambling.
Um, yeah, see, this is the boomer energy.
And to be honest, to be fair, Morgan has less of it than I do.
I, I hate this because I'm not a fan of the baby boomers at all.
So it really bothers me.
I have this boomer technological energy.
What's going on, man?
No, it's not, it's not you.
It is in fact, the technology because, uh, I could not accept your, your co-host invite.
So I just tried to join as a, as a speaker, but then I would, after that, I would get another
co-host invite and that would boot me down to listener.
And so I just, I just, uh, recycled the program and reopened and Hey, I'm at speaker.
Now I'm just going to leave it at this.
If it, if it's working now, we have in, in your session data, right?
I was just talking about another remote view.
Now all remote viewers get, then I'm aware of, um, end up getting paranormal session data
from time to time.
And with some of them, like some people get into remote viewing who are like super into
paranormal topics, but some people aren't believe it or not.
And I think sometimes they almost experienced a skepticism towards the other remote viewers
because of the paranormal nature of some of the sessions, right?
With the paranormal nature of the data from some of the sessions.
And so then they, um, they do it themselves.
They may not get the same level of paranormal data, but I've never seen anyone not to come
back with some, some of it.
Right.
So, uh, you guys have a lot over the years, but I mean, probably more than you expected,
maybe less than some of the other people.
Right.
But I mean, that's a fear.
Something's going on.
Oh yeah.
A hundred percent.
And you know, I've been thinking about it.
Actually, exactly what you just said over the last couple of days.
And that is that, yeah, over the years, um, it's never been any of our main focus, but
it, you know, the, the UFO situation has always been of interest to, um, you know, each of
us individually, you know, personally throughout our lives.
And so sure, we've worked actually a good amount of, uh, UFO or anomalous phenomena targets,
um, over the years.
And yeah, I, I think it's actually probably at the point where it would be worthwhile compiling
that data and, and putting it out as a data set.
Just, you know, what, what have we got?
What have we come across?
And, you know, what is, what does that contribute to the bigger picture?
Um, so it's, you know, it's interesting that you actually mentioned that too.
Yeah.
So I think like the best thing to do, right.
Is to start off by eliminating what we usually talk about by saying, you know, just kind of
summarizing it.
Right.
Um, the, the canon material, um, that, that comes from the intuitive underground sessions, um, specifically
related to the nature of reality.
It's our conclusion, uh, from that we have some conclusions or some strong indications from
that data.
And that definitely has a lot to do with disclosure.
As a matter of fact, I think it is the primary secret of disclosure.
I'm going to tell you that right now, that when Tim Burchette goes on Joe Rogan and says,
Jimmy Carter cried at his desk.
All right.
And then this is what he relates.
Okay.
He relates that Jimmy Carter was told that, um, you know, religions and civilizations were
created to keep us from destroying ourselves long enough for the aliens who quote created
us.
That's the claim, um, keep us from destroying ourselves long enough for them to complete their
experiments.
So the way that that, whenever you hear this stuff, right, there's always going to be a
spin and there's always going to be a lie or a set of lies or deceptions.
Right.
So what you look at is you say, like, break it down, you know, how does that fit into the
puzzle?
Right.
If this is a puzzle piece, how does it fit into the puzzle that we have?
And that usually strips away the deceptions or makes them pretty apparent.
Okay.
So creation is a, is a, is a, right.
That's a loaded term.
All right.
Because if we're right, and this is a simulation, then we're here in the simulation and someone
could say, look, we created them.
But what we're talking about a simulation, it's, it's biological.
That's run on actual people.
So, um, the creation would be the creation of the consciousness in the simulation, not the
creation of the people.
Right.
So right there saying it's like a false dichotomy that you either have to have, right.
Human beings were created by God or they were created by aliens entirely misses the, the third
option, um, which is we were, uh, created by God and hijacked by aliens.
And that's the one that actually fits the historical data, the mythological data, the religious data,
the esoteric data, right.
The other two are a false dichotomy.
So when Jimmy Carter was told that, like, you know, up until that point in history, human
beings supposedly didn't have nuclear weapons.
So there was never a period, right?
Like when you're talking about the middle ages, you wouldn't say, Hey, we have to create a
religion in order to keep people from destroying themselves.
Right.
Cause that wasn't a possibility at that time.
However, what, what that might mean if it were true would not be destroy themselves with
our technology, but stop having kids.
Now, why is that relevant?
Well, because whenever these Gnostic, quote, Gnostic movements, esoteric movements come
around, right.
Or not whenever, but when you look at history, right.
So what happened with people who wouldn't start following the Buddha or became a set of
Hindus, they joined Gnosticism.
They joined these different movements.
They didn't have children and they didn't have children because they believe that we were
in this, you know, artificial reality.
Right.
And so one way that that statement to keep people from destroying themselves while the
non-human intelligence completed its experiments, one way that could be true is to say, you
know, to keep people from, to continue having children, to maintain the social order, to keep
people reproducing so that, you know, the individuals involved in the experiment couldn't
stop the experiment prematurely.
So in that sense, right, like there might be some truth to those statements.
And, and those apparently the statements that they are going to come out with, that's what
they're indicating at some point.
And if they do come out with that, that will be the deception involved.
The deception involved will be like, this is all there is.
And, um, you know, we have this evidence as opposed to saying like, we were hijacked and
we were placed in this false situation.
So that is the conclusion that we've drawn from some of the session materials that we're in
this, we're in a simulation based on, it's a, it's a biotechnical simulation.
It's not just a computer simulation.
And, you know, because of that, we're real people.
We're just, this isn't real.
The experience we're having isn't real.
So that, that, that makes a big difference between our, what we're arguing and what other
simulation theorists argue.
So within that context, it changes the way you look at non-human intelligence, changes
the way you look at extraterrestrials, right?
It makes some things a lot simpler to understand.
So when we're talking about these ultra terrestrials, interdimensional, ultra terrestrial, plasma
based, Dajin, right?
Griefers who show up here and mess around like a bunch of, um, high school kids griefing in
Minecraft, right?
Where they go in there and they just try to cause as much pain and suffering and misery
for the other players as they can.
Like when that seems to categorize the behavior of the paranormal, scaring people, freaking
people out, leaving people with questions they can't answer, doing weird things.
Um, I don't know why my voice is cracking, please, excuse me, doing weird things.
Um, right.
That's one way that you can easily explain that is that, you know, we may, while we may be
stuck in a simulation, there may be others who can come and go, right?
So that's one of the ways it changes things.
And our original, you know, during some of our original, um, spaces, one of the things
I pointed out was, I didn't invent this idea.
Um, there is a strong archetypal similarity between the abduction experience and having medical
procedures performed on one so that it started out as less medical.
It's become more medical.
And when you get into screen imagery, right?
The concept of, of having false memories placed over real events, you could genuinely have people
who are experiencing these abductions being subjected to medical procedures.
And just not remembering accurately or having a false memory disguising what actually happened
to them.
And that's something that could happen to somebody in, right?
A material universe, but it's also something that could be an artifact of being in a simulation
where you would have people inside the simulation, having memories of things that occurred outside
the simulation, which would all be medical experiments, right?
However, that's not all the remote viewing, right?
So we, everyone who listens to our spaces knows that we talk about that, but that's not all
it talks about, right?
So we've got the ultra terrestrials.
We've got the, whatever it is showing up.
We've got the people who created the simulation, um, whom Morgan and Dan refer to as the space
dicks.
And I think inherent in that is the concept that they are space fearing, right?
But not space fearing here, space fearing at base reality, right?
I mean, I don't know why else you would call them space dicks.
Um, but there also seem to be something akin to extraterrestrials.
Within this reality.
Does that, does that sound like an accurate statement from based on session data that you've
seen?
Well, yeah, yes.
Um, to me anyways, it's a little less clear when we're talking inside the reality overlay.
Um, but definitely outside.
Yes.
Um,
well, it's almost hard to tell, right?
Because when you're, when you're remote viewing, um, if we're, if we're in a simulation and
we're looking up at the stars, right?
We could assume that the stars that we're looking at are a rendering of the stars at base level
reality.
So if you remote view Beetlejuice, um, you know, it's quite possible you're remote viewing
Beetlejuice at base level reality.
I mean, it would be difficult to parse that, right?
Particularly the further you get from where we are, metaphorically speaking.
Now, I know, I remember Dan saying that he wondered if the simulation was the size of a galaxy, right?
Like it might not just be earth.
It might not just be the solar system.
We could be in a galaxy size simulation.
I'm not saying that's the case.
I'm saying that's like something that he speculated on.
And that would possibly explain why there might be, um, extraterrestrial interactions inside of the reality of a lake, which is, uh, is speculation, right?
But it does seem to be, and I can think of a couple of the, the, some of the session data that you saw that might suggest that, right?
Like I, I can think of, um, you had session data where you looked at a, a potential Dyson spear star.
Yes.
There we go.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't, I wouldn't use the term Dyson sphere for that.
Definitely not.
But I know what you're talking about.
Um, and okay, ultimately, yeah, everything that, um, you, you summarize Dan's speculation, um, I'm more or less in line with that.
It's sound reasoning.
Um, it seems logical.
It fits the data that we're confident with.
Um, so, you know, tentatively, yes, I believe that that's what's going on.
Um, in, you know, base reality, we have, you know, for lack of a better term, you know,
interstellar, uh, travel to some, to some extent, there are entities or species that can do that.
Right.
They're the ones that were involved in the war that we referenced, right?
There, we are one of the parties and they are one of the parties that we, and whoever our allies were, were at war with.
Um, and yeah, they did not originate from earth as we did in our initial, uh, humanoid earthbound form.
Um, so yeah, it stands to reason that, that, um, that situation was, would be modeled potentially one-to-one, uh, within the simulation or reality overlay, the, uh, the virtual reality, if you will.
Um, I had a conversation with, uh, quick conversation with, uh, direct the other day about the, the use of the term virtual reality and how that, uh, that kind of really actually sums it up nicely in that it is both virtual and a reality.
Um, it fits with the concept, uh, or the analogy of dream, uh, maybe more than analogy that we often use.
But yeah, so that is, I would agree with that, the dream part.
Hey, you know, just to digress for one second, I don't want to bring everyone else into my stuff, but you know, next time you talk to direct, can you apologize to, to, to him for me?
Um, I was just under a lot of pressure at, at the time.
Um, I ended up blocking direct perception because I, I was upset about something that was going on back during the dot saw list situation.
And it really had nothing to do with him.
Um, and it was really just an asshole maneuver that made sense to me at the time, but I wasn't thinking clearly cause I was concerned about what was going on.
Um, I'm, I'm far from infallible.
Right.
And I'm not saying like, I'm not saying he should forget it.
I'm just saying that if you, if you talk to him, I'd just like you to let him know that I, I, I am apologetic for it.
That's all.
Um, it was inappropriate to me.
Yeah.
No, sure thing.
Sure thing.
Yeah.
Um, so yeah, I mean, cause he's an innocuous person.
Like he's, he seems like a decent sort, you know, and very knowledgeable about remote viewing and whatever.
It was just, anyhow.
So going back to this.
Um, so yeah, outside the reality overlay, outside the simulation, interstellar space fearing, um, beings at least one faction, if not several factions, um, referred to as the space dicks, uh, presently by the, by the intuitive underground group.
Um, however, inside, right.
Um, at one point in time, uh, and I don't have to, you don't have to mention anything that makes you uncomfortable, right.
About this session data, you can skip over like the, anything specifically that makes you uncomfortable.
But at one point in time, one of your viewers had a, a ship over their house and you remote viewed that ship and the session data indicated that it was extraterrestrial.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
So, and that's within, right.
That's within the, I mean, I might tell, look, I'm not going to lie.
I'm probably going to tell that story in my, the five things remote viewers don't want to talk about, but I'm not going to put you on the spot.
Right.
So that's, there we go.
Um, uh, yeah.
So they do see extraterrestrials and every remote viewer that I can think of.
Uh, sees something extraterrestrial.
But what happens is we get caught up in this like interdimensional.
That's one thing.
Plasma based.
Two.
Ultraterrestrial.
Three.
Um, different extraterrestrial species.
Four.
And multidimensional is actually sort of five, right.
Because there's like interdimensional, um, in the sense of, I mean, I think interdimensional is code for outside the simulation.
I do.
That's me.
All right.
However, there are remote viewers who see, um, levels, right.
Levels of reality.
And, um, technology on those other levels.
That is not at base level reality.
So we're talking about like a Russian nested doll here, right.
We're not talking about just, is this phenomenon real to us?
And we're saying, yeah, it is.
But we're also saying that like, some of it is like base level outside of the doll itself, outside of the leveled simulation.
But there's a leveled simulation in play.
And there may be something where this came up.
And again, not to put Morgan on the spot for this, because we didn't, he didn't view this target.
Right.
But that was one of the arguments that erupted in the remote viewing community around 3I Atlas.
There were people saying they remote viewed 3I Atlas and they saw extraterrestrials inside 3I Atlas.
There were other people saying they remote viewed it and they saw no extraterrestrials there.
But the third one was probably just as common, if not more common than the other two.
They remote viewed it and saw extraterrestrials there on a different level of reality.
Now, of course, you can't, right, you can't, um, there's no way to get feedback for that.
There's no way to, to ascertain whether it's true or false or whether the, the, the, um, viewer is on target.
It's entirely speculative.
However, like that does pop up in the, in the data that there are levels to reality.
Right.
I mean, how would you would explain it to me?
Like Earth's on top of Earth's or I believe you had a special way of explaining it, but maybe I'm just, maybe I'm wrong.
Oh yeah.
If you're asking, no, um, layers is, is kind of the idea that keeps coming up.
So there could be extraterrestrials or something else on a different layer, right?
Like hypothetically, there could be inside of the simulation, something that seems extraterrestrial that can observe us or interact with us that we can't directly perceive or interact with.
That's how crazy it gets, right?
That, that is the, is the disturbing part of the phenomenon.
That is what they're not disclosing to people, right?
People waiting to hear, um, when I was younger, it was people waiting to hear, yes, they're real.
They eat spaghetti.
Oh, we got a request.
Sorry, twigs.
I'll bring you up.
Um, you know, they, they have houses and kids and eat spaghetti and, you know, live where,
you know, on the planet Zeelon or something.
Um, and they evolved to the air and they're visiting here and it's all very Darwinistic.
And now people are waiting.
It seems like in the, in the UFO community on X, everyone seems like to be waiting to hear,
no, it's all a psyop.
It's all a hoax.
They don't exist at all, which is crazy.
It's like the, it's the aurorobos, right?
It's a snake biting its own tail.
Like the psyops piled on psyops have, have, have been so successful that now like the
counterculture perspective is that the whole thing is a psyop as opposed to when I was younger.
Uh, twigs, I can't see if you're up as a listener or speaker.
So if you're a speaker, you can just, uh, you can just talk and say, yeah.
Like, they are good.
Yep.
Cool.
So, um, and the truth is probably in between, right?
So now we've got these new psyops.
We have the angels and demons.
Now, does that mean that there aren't angels and demons?
No.
As a matter of fact, there's RV data on angels and demons, right?
Does that mean they're all angels and demons?
That is not the same.
One does not follow from the other.
So whenever you end up with individuals coming out and saying that they're right, they're,
they're part of a, you know, of a covert government organization of one kind or another, and they've
got a story and that story seems it's not holistic, right?
And it doesn't, it seems to fit with one segment or demographic set of beliefs.
Like you have to kind of question that immediately because social engineering, that's how that works,
right?
So I, as a, as a matter of historical note, this is not technical RV.
It's just a minor digression, right?
But, you know, when we study astrology, we studied the, the, the connection of Neptune and,
and Pluto and their conjunction in the 1800s, right?
That is when the whole occult thing happened.
And that's also when the whole UFO thing happened, starting from that period.
And people forget that was when the airship sightings began.
Right.
And, and if you work your way up, right?
Until the fifties or sixties, there was a strong correlation between occultism and UFO phenomenon.
So are people going to say like that correlation doesn't exist or it clearly existed?
Um, the people who were involved in the, uh, the rocket scientist science, right?
Like they, um, Jack Parsons was the, uh, uh, according to, um, Alistair Crowley was the most important person involved in the magical community.
So it's, it's definitely there, but what's interesting is, um, what's interesting is it's so clear at this point that there's an impetus to get people to really just accept that there aren't any extraterrestrials at the same time they're releasing the data.
And the people who have been working in this for a long time saying, no, of course there are extraterrestrials.
What are you talking about?
So that's sort of come out of nowhere.
Um, and that's why I wanted Morgan to clarify that we have data, um, with all of the different, um, scenarios.
So it seems like everything is a little bit true, right?
But the main right key to understanding it is that what we accept is our regular day-to-day reality.
That's the thing that really seems to be false from the perspective of the RV data.
Um, we have a picture and Morgan is going to talk about some session.
It doesn't work there, but twigs, I want to give you a chance to, to introduce, introduce yourself and, and say what is on your mind.
Oh, Hey, um, yeah, there's, uh, I suppose introduction.
I don't know.
I don't need some introduction, really.
Are you Canadian like Morgan?
Yeah, I'm Canadian.
Oh, there you go.
Perfect.
I'm, uh, well, I'm human.
Nice to meet you.
Um, that's the bullshit.
That's the problem.
Um, we're alive that like, there's so much division and so necessary.
Um, religion is division, but there is like, I, my theory on it is that like culture, like independent
areas of the world have their own multi-dimensional, multi-versial, um, guidance.
And that is like, you can see it portrayed across different, um, civilizations, different
cultures across the world.
And like, you know, the, the, the older cultures had more, more understanding of what, what is
the clear and abhorrent problem here.
And like, if you compare the, say the street structure of Tenochtitlan to like the very,
very up close, uh, imagery of a chip, you'll, you'll see it.
And if you understand that, you'll understand what the problem is.
And I know what I come across is like, I like, like idealistic, but it's not idealistic.
It's just people just fucking living in harmony and stuff.
Well, that would, that would be nice.
Right.
But one of the, um, one of the important things about this discussion, um, you know, the discussion
of, uh, NHI extraterrestrials, plasma entities, gin, space sticks, whatever.
We want to call the various elements of the phenomenon.
And there seemed to be various elements of phenomenon.
One thing that seems very clear is that it's in some of their interests for us not to get
along.
Right.
And so the first book I always recommend, I recommended earlier, but I think it was before
you were here.
The first book I think anyone should read when they start studying ufology is the book,
the gods of Eden by William Bramley.
And that is the, uh, central thesis of that book.
That there is a tremendous historical evidence for interaction with the phenomenon, but right.
The main takeaway from that isn't whether the phenomenon is real or not.
The important part of that historical evidence is that it almost entirely relates to an attempt
to divide, um, human beings, to provoke conflict, to divide human beings, to control the population.
And he goes through the different periods of history and the, the sightings and how they
correlate with plagues and wars and natural disasters.
You know, a lot of us to give you one minor example, right?
Like a lot of us are familiar with the image of the grim reaper, but a lot of people don't
realize that the origin of the image of the grim reaper was that the men dressed like tall
men, very tall men dress like plague doctors, you know, with the long nose, right.
And the black clothing were often seen in fields in the, in the fields, in the farms around,
cause the village would often be surrounded by fields back then.
It was right.
The way they would farm was different from how we farm now.
It was like communal plots that surrounded the village.
And so they would wake up and they would see these tall guys out there waving something that
looked like a scythe in the grain.
And the next day, everyone would start to die of the plague.
So that's not something that was reported a few times.
That's something that was reported throughout the period of the plague, right?
They also have the, the green mists that would come in.
So that's not directly related to UFOs, but it is related to disclosure, right?
Because one of that, the facets of the disclosure is the, you know, there are guys like Stephen
Greer out there who are going to tell you that, oh no, this is great.
Like the universe is full of friendly people.
That is not what, that is not what history shows us.
And it's definitely not what the remote viewing data shows us.
Um, and Morgan would be the expert on that, but I've never seen remote viewing data that would
tend to suggest that, to be honest.
Uh, we had someone else pop up.
Um, WTF, I think I let you up, but, uh, my screen gets frozen.
So I can't see who's up as a speaker or not.
So if you're here and you want to say something, go ahead.
Sure.
Hey guys, uh, JT, I just popped in and, uh, you know, um, I've been, I always, uh, kind
of avoid, uh, I'm assuming you guys aren't going to do a session tonight, but I avoid them
because I've got, like, I've done six and all six I hit on and I just, I never want to do
any more because it's like, well, you don't want to, you don't want to be way off on one.
Right.
And I was just doing them for fun.
And I'm like, God, it's like, cause I do them for fun and I just don't even try.
I think that's like the key, right?
I don't know, man.
And it's always the first one that comes to you.
It's crazy.
Like, you know, you're supposed to draw it down.
And that first one comes and like, you know, it's like, and I'm like, oh no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, that's just some BS that I just made up in my mind.
Let's take this seriously.
And as soon as I start to take it seriously, I just draw everything that's wrong.
And then it's always the first thing that gets imprinted on my mind.
But obviously there's pros like Dick Allgaier that have way realistic techniques that I don't
have and they can go way farther.
But anyways, you were mentioning data and that's when I really wanted to come up because you
mentioned data and I'm like, oh, I should probably mention that I follow Cliff High.
Um, because like you were saying in disclosure, there's always connections with, uh, wars,
plagues, viruses, and, um, in, in the data for Cliff High, there's all of these things.
And again, not a profit.
Um, I don't care if anyone is, that's totally fine with me, but I respect people much more
that totally are willing to, um, say this is just in the data.
It doesn't mean that I think it's going to come true with this.
It's just, it's only in the data from web scrapes from 2001.
And, um, I am always in like, he's always analyzing his own consciousness and how he could
be misinterpreting things.
And that's kind of me too.
Like, I don't think anything that I've seen, um, is, uh, you know, like, I don't know,
just a lot of respect for people that kind of doubt themselves, which is totally me.
Um, and it's like, man, I, I have definitely like had, uh, very near term future things
come true five hours after I've seen them in my mind to a T, um, like a complete detailed
description, everything that I saw then came true five hours later.
But yeah, let me, let me take it from there.
Um, people with, uh, natural intuitive ability do have experiences like that.
You, you very well may have some Morgan would be the person who could judge that.
Uh, Morgan is, um, so Dick is, uh, is an experienced remote viewer.
Um, I'm not, uh, we're, this isn't, we're not running a, uh, uh, a space on future forecasting.
We might, at some point we've talked about them in the past.
Um, Morgan is, uh, as experienced, if not more experienced than, um, my cohost, Morgan,
you can meet him right now, Morgan Farrell, than anyone in the future forecasting, um, crew.
Uh, he's got 15 years and, uh, he's a remote viewing instructor.
And if you have interest in, um, in refining your abilities remote viewer, go ahead.
I would have to say, no, that's technically not, that's not, that's not accurate.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
A lot of the guys in FFG have, they've been around longer than me.
Definitely.
Really?
Oh yeah, absolutely.
Dick?
Okay.
Well, all right.
So maybe not, uh, I'll have to check the, I'll have to check that because I, I seem to
remember Dick getting involved in 2012, 2013 with, with more,
around the same time, but I could be incorrect.
Oh, okay.
So I will, I will check that.
Algaier specifically, I don't know when he started.
I don't know.
So I can't say about him, but I know some of the other guys.
But Daz might've been around longer.
Daz has definitely been around longer.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Okay.
So without Daz, yeah.
Ed hasn't.
I know that.
Uh, you, you had about the same amount of time as Ed.
And I think that you have the same amount of time as, as Dick.
Okay.
Anyhow, this isn't about them.
We don't want to like be flaming them.
All I'm going to say is that, you know, um, I know Daz and I like Daz.
I have no problem with him.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
I'm saying no.
Yeah.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm addressing WTF and saying like you and I, but particularly you don't want to, this
isn't about like comparing, attrassing and criticizing.
I'm saying as Morgan's friend that, you know, when you're, when you're talking, looking for
experts, you can consider Morgan to be an expert at the same level.
That was on my point, but we want to be sensitive.
So it kind of gets, you know what I mean?
We start hemming and hawing.
Oh, a hundred percent.
Um, yeah.
Sorry guys.
That was a peripheral comment.
Like nothing.
That's okay.
But no, but I want to take that second part.
I want to take the second part.
Okay.
Um, cliff high is not, uh, related to technical remote viewing.
Um, cliff high, uh, the web bots, I've followed them from the very inception of, um, of half
past human and urban survival with Georgia, which is where I learned about cliff high, uh,
from 1999 on.
I don't follow cliff high very often.
Um, now he took a, a rather dark and sinister turn along the way.
Now, what I will say about that is, um, that cliff high, particularly in originally in
the first 10 or 15 years was very open about the fact that he was a diagnosed paranoid
schizophrenic.
So he says that he's not making a joke.
He doesn't say it as often, but even a few years ago, he would still talk about it, but
it's not a, when people say that about him, they're not disparaging him.
They might be disparaging him, but it also happens to be true.
So, uh, he's a bright guy and, uh, the web bots are for real.
They definitely predict things years in advance.
I, I, coronavirus showed up in the predictions in 2003, Greta Thunberg showed up in the predictions
in 2007.
I think that I, that I can recollect.
Right.
So I would never tell people don't pay attention to what cliff high has to say and with the
web bots.
Um, but as the years have gone on, um, he, he has gotten kind of, uh, he's gone a little
bit off the rails with his ideology.
And so it's important to mention that to people because sending people that way, you know,
you might support it and that's okay.
But, you know, I don't want to leave it without comment because I don't want people to understand
to, to, um, to think that we support it.
Right.
Some of his conclusions.
So I just want to leave it at that with cliff eyes, the web bots, they're real.
Um, people have to make their own decisions or, uh, uh, you know, have to make their own
judgment.
But, um, his positions have changed radically in the last few years.
Right.
To the extent that over the last, since COVID, right.
Like to the extent that you wouldn't find his, him, his positions on a lot of subjects, you
wouldn't be able to really, um, it's like a different person.
Right.
And it was to the extent that people for a few years thought that he'd been co-opted by
the intelligence services or something.
Um, I'm not saying that was the case.
I'm just saying that's how profound the flip was.
So I'll just take that for what it's worth.
Um, anyways, I wanted to pop back to technical remote viewing and disclosure, uh, Twigs, I
saw your hand up.
You want to, um, yeah, has nobody mentioned the minister.
I read the minister.
It goes like, I think it was a 14 when I read this.
I think I read that in tandem with, um, not something else, but, um, that to me was just
what led, like that was a 14.
That was 18 years ago.
And that led me down at MKUltra and all of the, the actual, the real psyops.
I have trouble sometimes understanding people.
It's me.
It's because I was in an accident.
Can you just repeat that again?
The name of the, the book or article?
The men who stare at goats.
Oh, the men who stare at goats.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that was like, I don't know when, maybe it was a 14.
I'm not sure when that was when I was, I was young teen.
Anyway, yeah.
But, um, yeah, that led me down the road of, of MKUltra, like back to the, the, the, what
is it called?
Oh, I had the name of it recently.
It's the bell.
I know the German bell.
It led me down all along that route.
And it was like, that was so long ago, you know?
Um, yeah.
The German bell is real.
That's so that, that came out.
Yeah.
I didn't know the name, but I know the name.
I know the name.
What is the name?
Tell me.
Cause it's, it's.
No, it's something involving bell.
Uh, you're right.
I'm not going to be able to think of it now, but it has a German name and, uh, you know,
it's, uh, they were flying around 1100, 1500 miles an hour.
And, um, now there's been a lot of apocryl stories about time travel and things like that.
But what came out at least in the disclosure documents was that it was, uh, it was a flying machine.
Yeah.
Who was laughing at us while we were shooting at them in the battle of Los Angeles?
Uh, yeah.
I mean, I think we're getting, we're getting a little bit far away from the technical remote viewing.
So I'm going to circle back, but I think we were fighting the Japanese in the battle of Los Angeles, to be honest with you.
They had, um, yeah, they had some, uh, some, some blimps.
They had these super blimps and, um, you know, airplanes weren't able to fly that high.
Like, but during World War II blimps were still able to fly a lot higher than airplanes were.
It wasn't until after that, that the airplanes were able to fly that high, but that's like a, that could be another, um, yeah, that could definitely be another, uh, space.
So Morgan, I wanted to circle back to the picture that you would, um, you would send me.
Oh, okay.
Well, hang on, hang on.
Give me a sec.
Uh, JT cover for me.
For like one minute.
You don't have his back.
Yeah, no, I can always talk.
Go ahead, man.
Twix, what?
I was just calling you out for not having your buddy's back when he, uh, when he asked you.
No, you know, I had my mic off.
I was talking, I did have his back, but I was talking to dead air.
He's got, he's got, he's got some session data, right?
So he's got something related to, uh, a target they ran on, um, uh, session data.
So they, they've run a lot of targets.
We didn't have a really chance to prepare very much.
Um, the disclosure thing is something that I, I kind of, me and many other people, right?
Predicted.
But we were ready for a different topic tonight.
And it just so happens that the disclosure thing dropped.
So we've been running these spaces for over a year.
We've run over 40 spaces.
I've, most of them just myself, but we've run a lot together and, uh, we could run another
40 just on the, um, the different data that we have, right?
The, that data he has from remote viewing and the historical data, um, the, you know, people
don't necessarily pay as much attention sometimes.
And that's not like a complaint.
What I'm saying is, you know, people have, um, what, what, what happens in this community
is that people get, they have confirmation bias.
They have a, a theory, right?
Something that a subsection interests them that maybe they're interested in, in plasma
beings and they start to perse, you know, perseverate on plasma beings and everything becomes a plasma
being, right?
Or the angels and demons.
Now everything is an angel or demon.
And so people only look for data or information that backs up what they want to see.
That's what they find entertaining.
That's what they find interesting.
So when they see people, uh, you know, when they see videos, when they see articles, when
they see spaces on that subject, right?
Like they will listen to those and they won't pay attention to the other ones.
And so the problem with that is, is we're at this point right now where the documents
are beginning to flow.
It's not going to make a damn bit of difference, right?
Because everyone has, is in an echo chamber.
Everyone is sort of siloed is the term between these different interpretations of the, of the
phenomenon.
And what's really happening is that they're all kind of true, right?
And, um, as long as people are fighting about what, you know, is it angels or demons?
Is it ultra terrestrials, extra terrestrials that live under the ground and live in the
ocean, right?
As long as we're all fighting about that, then it doesn't matter what documents they release.
They can release the entire truth.
And it won't matter because everyone will be, uh, uh, caught up in this sectarian conflict
over the, the different interpretations.
So we have the, the, the photo, which was the target, uh, up in the, the nest.
I don't see much when I'm looking at the photo, but that's just me.
So I don't know if Morgan has fully explained it to me.
I think he has in the past and I just kind of blanked on it.
Go ahead.
So what we have here, if you guys want to check it out, I posted in the replies and, um, I
bumped it up into the nest.
So what we have here, that's just, that's the targeting material that I used.
So, so what, what I did was, um, so our team, uh, the intuitive underground, we're actually,
we're in the middle of a project right now.
I mean, I, I, almost all times we have a project, um, in some stage of progress.
Um, so I kind of decided on a whim, uh, late last night to send out an email to the team.
And I said, Hey, um, if anyone wants to run a quick side project, uh, give me a session
in the next, you know, 12 hours or so.
And I just sent, uh, uh, this set of TRMs here and what I had them look at.
And of course, you know, they're operating blind, um, standard operating procedure and
all of that.
Um, now the way that I've targeted this here, uh, I've taken a screen grab from one of the
videos that was apparently, actually it's been released previously, but anyways, it was among
the batch that was released the other day there.
So what I did was I took a screen grab and I pointed the target reference numbers directly
at the moving object in the frame.
So what that means, uh, from a, uh, from an operating standpoint is I'm intending the viewer's attention
to be turned directly to that object to tell me what that is.
That's the primary objective.
Uh, anything beyond that is, uh, we would consider contextual data.
So, um, when the session started rolling in, um, and keep in mind with such a, with out of
the blue total short notice, um, uh, the, the intention here was not to run a full length
project, which would take a couple of days at least, you know, 48 hours or, or more.
Um, but the intention here was to just have the guys run a quick kind of preliminary pass
and just kind of give me an overview of basically kind of, what is this thing?
What are we looking at here?
And right away, um, you know, as soon as I started looking at, at the results as, as I
started coming in, um, you know, my initial reaction was, okay, well, I'm noticing, you
know, the, the basic descriptions, um, you know, natural landscape, man-made structures
and a, an object in motion, um, they were all describing it as man-made.
Um, there was, there was nothing in the data that indicated that this specific object in
this specific video, um, is actually anything anomalous at all.
Um, so, um, okay.
That's, that's really, that's all I wanted the guys to do.
So I sent them their feedback.
Um, and I got a reply from one of the viewers, uh, just before I hopped on here, um, tonight.
And he said, okay, I have a couple of thoughts.
Um, he's talking, he's not just talking to me here.
He's saying in general, don't get your hopes up.
This is, um, at best military human, military tech.
Um, he's making the comparison to, you know, like a flyover exhibition sort of thing.
Um, but he says, you know, in a session, he had indication of, uh, in basically information
control.
He said, this is part of a bigger information control campaign.
Um, he says, you know, there's going to be, there's going to be more videos, you know,
have people, um, basically debunking, um, this video in particular.
And I'm sure a lot of the other ones I've actually seen some of the other ones, you know,
readily debunked.
Um, and that, you know, that's absolutely the case.
Um, now he makes an interesting kind of a prediction here based on some of his session
data, he says, you get, you get these excited people and you're, he, he thinks you're going
to see people now camping out around, you know, area, like places they aren't necessarily
supposed to be, you know, trying to get a glimpse at something and to try and see this
stuff again.
Um, but he really, he emphasizes here.
So you can think of this as part of the bigger UFO disclosure thing, controlling the information
and kind of acclimatizing the population, um, so that they don't necessarily know what to
think about this.
Um, I had like a five minute discussion with them, um, on the phone again, right before
I, I hopped on here and yeah, he just really wanted to emphasize kind of that, that last
point, like, you know, he kind of made the comparison to, you know, he said, you're, you're,
you're gonna, you're gonna see probably in the fairly near future, um, we're actually
seeing things that you don't immediately recognize in the sky actually is rather unremarkable.
Um, you know, it's, it's almost like an inoculation, uh, might've been the word that he used,
like being, uh, inoculated, you know, against, um, and so-called anomalous activity in the
sky.
So I, and, and it was interesting because these, um, these, these session results here, um,
they actually highlight, you know, um, something that I think is, is really important to you.
And that is just, you know, the fact that, you know, as we discussed earlier, sure, there
absolutely are, um, anomalous, uh, you know, extraterrestrial, interdimensional, uh, you
know, uh, reality hopping intelligences that can and do exist and interact with, uh, us here
individually and, you know, societally.
That is all true.
However, a lot of reports, a lot of videos are actually completely innocuous.
Um, in fact, I think the word innocuous was literally in this, in this, the raw session
data.
So, you know, it just, it kind of highlights, uh, an important distinction.
Anyways, that's my little presentation with no crap whatsoever.
No, cool.
Um, I, I appreciate that.
Cause that was, I keyed in on something very important.
I'd like to ask you, um, uh, separately, uh, later on this, um, uh, later on, I want to
ask you about, um, secret space program stuff to see if it's ever shown up in your, in your
data.
But first, uh, before we go to, uh, twigs, I want to, um, follow up on the inoculation idea.
So, um, we know that, right.
The government has this technology.
We know they do.
Um, I shouldn't be a surprise to anyone.
One of the issues that I have with like the whole UFO X thing, um, and online ufology is
that it's, it's become preoccupied with, um, revealing classified military, um, secrets.
And you have to wonder like how much of that is, um, how much of that is just that we've
got generations of Americans who no longer take national security seriously, but you also
have to wonder like, and I'm not pointing the fingers at any particular person, right?
I'm, I'm really not.
What I'm saying is you always have to wonder that if you have a group of 3000 or 5,000 people
advocating or 50,000 people advocating for the release of classified U S weapons technology,
right?
Um, one way or the other through whistleblowers, right?
Um, a certain percentage of those people are going to be in the employee of a foreign intelligence
agencies, right?
That's just a fact.
It's just a fact.
I mean, if you, you know, the American hobbyists might want to know, you know, and millennials
and people are like, maybe a little autistic, whatever, like there might be a whole fact
groups of people out there who want to know for different reasons, like what type of spaceships
we have, but, um, the Chinese, the Russians, the Iranians, the Venezuelans, the English,
the French, right?
Like there are a lot of other groups out there that also want to know exactly what we, you
know, what type of spaceships we have now.
It's, I wanted to throw this out there because I don't think there's any TRV data on this
subject right now, or at least with Morgan's group, but probably with other groups, right?
There are potential break, breakaway civilizations, right?
That, um, aren't just, um, the whole Nazi thing, right?
Cause we all know about the, the idea of a potential Nazi breakaway civilization.
Um, there are, um, stories, uh, uh, uh, potential breakaway civilization from way back under Mount
Shasta.
That's one of the paranormal stories that's gone, gone around for a long time.
I don't know if Morgan's group has ever looked at Mount Shasta, but a lot of remote
being groups have, and they've seen very anomalous information, right?
Um, I can, there's a potential breakaway civilization that emerged prior to world war II.
Uh, there were the, um, there were, uh, clubs that were building airships in California,
uh, uh, mostly German immigrants.
Um, and it's been speculated that, uh, they may have become more advanced technologically.
Um, there is, uh, Marconi.
I don't know if anyone is familiar with this story, but, um, the inventor of the radio, uh,
disappeared.
And what happened was he, um, supposedly he and a group of, of the other leading scientists
of the time, uh, got together and left and went to build a city in the middle of the Amazon
rainforest.
And there was speculation years ago that some of the UFO sightings could be, um, them as
a, as a breakaway civilization in the Amazon rainforest of scientists who were ahead of the, ahead
of the curve, um, but beat the Nazis by like 30 years.
Right.
And then, uh, something that, um, I think we're going to hear more about, cause we now
have someone who's sort of like specializes in this running shows on Sundays, the Sunday
syndicate, Gene Sticko, who, um, who has some documents that he, he got from his father-in-law
who was a former Soviet scientist.
So for whatever reason, they're bringing this out again, uh, it may just be completely coincidental.
It may not be completely coincidental, but something that people don't talk about anymore,
that was the subject of discussion in alternative circles, like really fringe circles in the eighties
and nineties, uh, seventies, eighties and nineties, really was the level of technological advancement
in the Soviet union.
The Soviet union was very technologically advanced.
They were very, it seemed like they were very, they've never, they never did a good job
with mass producing whatever they developed.
But as far as the intelligence of their scientists, like they were very advanced and there were stories
of, uh, directed energy weapons, mobile weapons platforms, uh, not the type of spaceships we're
talking about, but, you know, advanced craft coming out of the Soviet union during that time.
And what happened was the fall of the cold war.
And there is some evidence.
I'm not saying there's a lot of evidence, but there's some evidence that there is a, you could,
if you were looking at different groups, you could categorize as breakaway civilizations.
There, there was a group that inherited the, um, technological advances of the Soviet union
that may not be the current Russian government who do talk about having advanced weapons, by
the way, they do threaten us with advanced weapons fairly often, um, and have for decades said
that they were going to use, you know, energy weapons on us and all kinds of shit.
Right.
Um, earthquake weapons, uh, a member of the Duma took credit for the, um, the earthquake
that, uh, destroyed Fukushima.
So they do have advanced technology, but there may be another group that something akin to
a Soviet breakaway civilization.
So there are other groups that could be flying this stuff around in the air.
The reason that what Morgan said made me think of that is he's talking about inoculating people
to seeing this stuff in the air.
Right.
So you would do that if you thought that for instance, aliens were returning to the planet
or they were here, right?
If you had underground civilizations, underwater civilizations that were making themselves
known, if you had extraterrestrial civilizations that were making themselves known, right?
If you had breakaway civilizations that were making themselves known, or if you were edging
towards a war and you knew that not only were you going to be using your advanced technology
more often, but your adversaries were going to be using their advanced technology more often.
Right.
So people are going to be seeing all kinds of zip around up in the sky.
And it would kind of make sense to have an operation to inoculate people to seeing these
objects and not, you know, and not freaking out about it.
That's just, that's interesting from, from what he was saying.
It's interesting.
Go ahead, Twigs.
I have no idea as to why my hand is raised or what point I was, I was, uh, wow.
Yeah.
That is some, some very real and very, uh, part of our, our existence and stuff.
Like it's, uh, become a case of it's so obvious yet.
It's like the, you're going to hear different frequencies in the birds too, not only just
changes in the, uh, the sounds and planes and sights in the sky.
Um, there, the loss of control of, of, of, of, of the stack is just, it's obvious because
we're not dealing with extraterrestrials.
We're dealing with future iterations of our, our cultures.
I believe anyway, and these breakaway groups that we're talking about, we're not dealing
with something that doesn't know us better than we do, you know?
So we don't have a, uh, we don't have a character play here.
We just have to try to help our current selves.
Yeah.
I mean, so the thing with that is the, the remote viewing data, at least, um, seems pretty
clear that there are, um, there are extraterrestrial civilizations to what degree they're here.
I don't know.
Uh, Morgan, when they were looking at an, uh, an object that had been speculated as a potential
Dyson sphere, it wasn't the Dyson sphere, as he pointed out, but they saw a ship flying,
you know, stuck in a, in a star and, you know, people have speculated that stars could be
used as, as a, a gateway to travel through the galaxy for like highly advanced civilizations.
And they saw that, right?
So, um, there are targets.
Uh, I don't know if Mark Morgan's group has ever viewed Phobos.
I'm not that I'm aware of, but there is a phenomenon that some remote viewers, I don't,
again, like I have never talked to Morgan about this, so I don't know if they've ever
experienced it.
Right.
But there are the cardboard boxes.
There are some targets that when viewers look at them, they see stacks and stacks of
cardboard boxes.
And the speculation is that someone has developed a technique that allows them to mask what is
really there.
And that the screen image that they're capable of using is stacks of cardboard boxes.
I, I've heard numerous groups of remote viewers say that they see Phobos as packed full of cardboard
boxes.
And I've heard other people say that they've looked at other sensitive targets.
So the thing with this is, right?
Like he's talking about government technology.
There is good.
We know that.
Right.
And also technology, someone on earth has technology or someone's, right?
Different groups have, have this advanced technology.
You know, there are people, there are viewers who look at classified, there are viewers who, who
look at, uh, uh, targets that are like secret U S bases.
And they're like Americans.
It's just, again, I know that I'm, I'm, um, you know, I'm, I'm getting to the point where
I can start to say I'm from an older generation, unfortunately.
Right.
But like that, you want to talk about, there was a time when everyone, you know, for an
American, right.
And, and Canadians in Canada and English people in England, right.
Like coming out of world war two citizens of the, of, of nations took the national security
of their countries like very seriously.
That would be, you know, that's just crazy that people will put out videos on YouTube of
remote viewing secret American basis.
Now, I don't know if they're on target.
I don't know if what they're putting out is, is, is accurate, but the fact that they're
pointing, putting it out.
Like, I, I, I just think that's nuts.
And I, I wouldn't have anything to do with that myself.
Now I'm not a remote viewer, but I wouldn't like, I wouldn't run a space on it.
Um, to be honest, I wouldn't, I wouldn't support disseminating that information, but it does
seem that there are extraterrestrials and one possible explanation for what's going on.
Right.
Like in the world right now.
Um, well, I mean, I can tell you, see, here we go.
So we have answers, right?
It's just crafting the answers in such a way that people can hear them or want to hear
them.
So we know to some extent, like what's going on.
Right.
We know that, um, we know that we're roving remote viewers in general.
And, and people who study adjacent, uh, topics know that we are headed towards some catastrophic
series of events.
And we know that the governments of the world know this and have known for a long time.
And that a lot of the stuff that they do that doesn't seem to make any sense does make sense
when you recognize that they are preparing for, uh, a world with less people in it.
What those catastrophic events, events are vary from group to group, right?
The, some of the, Lynn Buchanan, uh, amazing remote viewer from the original Stargate program,
uh, has, has seen the population of the U S at about a hundred million in the year 2040.
And he said that for years and his explanation, um, aside from some political events, uh, there's
some, sorry, diseases involved, uh, Stephen Schwartz, um, has done the largest remote viewing
studies, uh, what he categorizes remote viewing is questionable, but he himself is a trained
remote viewer.
Um, but what he categorizes, like when he does large research sets and he says that he's, you
know, worked with 5,000 remote viewers, that's, he's not really, he's not talking about people
like Morgan, right.
With extensive training.
However, he has run these projects, the 2050 and 2060 projects for, for decades now.
And the information that he's compiled is fairly consistent.
One of the pieces of that information, um, is that the population is much lower in 2050 and
2060 than it is today.
And his explanation was a series of natural disasters and a series of diseases.
Um, and it's hard to find the old radio recordings.
It's hard to find the old, um, videos, or at least it's hard for me to find them.
Um, but I believe COVID was something he predicted years prior to what's happening.
And he predicted other diseases will occur and natural disasters will occur.
That will lower our population.
That's one end.
The other end is a full on catastrophic pole shift event, magnetic pole shift event.
Uh, I say, I say, I say both because people vary in their interpretation.
There could be a, uh, solar coronal mass ejection.
Um, what is referred to as a micro nova and that micro nova could trigger, or it's referred, also referred to as the flash or in technical remote viewing, it's referred to as the kill shot.
So it could be a Carrington event, yeah, but the, what they foresee is probably something a little bit more extreme than Carrington event.
What's interesting is that just a Carrington event would be enough, right?
Just a Carrington event would be enough.
But you know, it's because we literally don't have the, in the natural field that we had then it's degrading.
And that's like, you seem to know the north pole has shifted.
How fast in the last five years?
Too fast.
Right.
Correct.
So that's, you know, what the end result of that crisis is, whether it ends with a magnetic pole shift, a, a Carrington event, or a full on Doomer Daddy, massive global, you know, shift in the crust as, as the, as the, as the, the, or,
you know, the surface of the earth moves around and it's, it's, it's common.
I've read up on this.
This was, this was eight years ago.
I read up on PRT and I wrote extensively about it.
Actually, I argued with a, a theoretical physicist on a bus to Ennis one day.
It was funny, but it's, it's naturally occurring.
It happens every what?
Two, 20,000 years.
Um, and yeah, it's going to be like an existential crisis for society as, as is.
Things are going to be, it's like the, the, the day after tomorrow basically is what it's going to be, especially weather-wise.
Um, and in terms of like UV, um, sunscreen ain't going to do.
Right.
So what I'm saying is that when it comes to disclosure, right?
Um, remote viewers have been seeing this stuff since the 1970s, 1980s, public remote viewers have been seeing it since the nineties.
Um, when Ed Names came out and created Psytech and began teaching people about the kill shot.
Uh, they have been anticipating it.
The United States government employs remote viewers as do major corporations and foreign governments.
Um, the Russian government may have a more advanced remote viewing program, um, than the United States ever has.
However, they do employ remote viewers and what has been happening.
And as well as technology that is capable of remote viewing, uh, according to whistleblowers.
So, um, two days ago or last night.
Yeah.
Was it not very unusual?
What was it?
Was there a very strange or, or like, uh, like highly unusual, um, Aurora in the last two days?
Uh, not here, but there've been highly unusual Aurora's going on for the last two years.
Yeah.
And yeah, no shifts of the clarity has been pulled further.
Obviously.
Look, you know, when I was growing up, you didn't see Aurora's in Massachusetts.
Right.
And you never would have expected to, and now you do.
So there's no question that this is, this is, uh, this is an ongoing breaking in a situation is breaking down.
What, what I'm trying to get at is like, we know that, right.
We know this is, is going to happen.
We know it's coming, right.
They all know it's coming and all the remote viewers know it's coming.
They all know, right.
You can't be in the remote viewing community without hearing this information from somebody.
If you haven't seen it yourself.
Uh, but what is the point?
Uh, the point we would say, um, the data that has come up, I think if you look at the IU, uh, data and then look at other remote viewers, not working with IU, who have seen similar, uh, data.
The, um, the, um, the simulation is being rebooted.
That is what happens with these periodic, um, these periodic cataclysms inside the simulation.
You experience the cataclysm outside the simulation.
You're rebooting the, the, the, the simulation, the data is being harvested.
It is being put on a physical medium and stored someplace.
And then the simulation is being rebooted to start again.
That, that is what is going on.
That is what we are approaching.
And everything that is happening is seen in that context.
Um, part of that though, right.
Is that as we get closer to this event, the world is going to get stranger and stranger.
It's going to get more novel as time goes on.
Because the point of the simulation slash reality overlay is probably to generate emergent solutions
to problems.
Cause that's why we create simulations.
We create simulations now here on planet earth.
And the reason we do it is to come up with novel solutions to all kinds of problems, whether
it's inventions, pharmaceuticals, right?
AI now is, is working on developing pharmaceuticals, uh, solving problems like, um, like the pole
shift slash the energy crisis, right?
There's a, there is a, a good reason to believe one of the purposes for all the data centers
showing up all over the world is to try to utilize AI and computer learning to try to figure
out a solution to the problem of this upcoming mega series of catastrophes, right?
That's so inside as above, so below as within, so without that is what is, um, is happening.
We can't expect to see things that seem crazy.
Okay.
Regardless of what your political leanings are, regardless of how you see the world, the events
of our time going back now, at least 10 years have been bat shit crazy from the perspective of
any human being 20 or 30 years ago, we never would have believed that it would happen.
We never would have believed the lockdowns.
We never want to believe COVID the pandemic.
And now we're heading into another pandemic.
Right.
And regardless of whether, however you feel about him, right?
Uh, it was a joke on the Simpsons that Trump could get elected president United States.
Right now I'm not saying you, you shouldn't feel however you want about him.
What I'm saying is it's part of the increasing novelty in society that things are getting stranger
and stranger.
that can, can it continue to seem stranger and you cannot rule out seeing some kind of potential,
both false and real potential extraterrestrial invasions, events, visitations, et cetera, because
that is yet another problem, very complex problem that would cause people to kind of generate solutions
to that problem.
And that's the point of what we're doing here.
So don't, you know, if, if they tell you that there's an alien invasion, right?
It could be completely false and media generated.
It could be biologically programmed organisms that are designed to look like aliens because
those also exist.
Okay.
And it could be actual aliens.
It could be all three.
Like we're just going to keep getting crazier and crazier until the, until there's a major
population reduction, because you're going to try to squeeze all the juice out of the lemon.
That, that is the large population that we have right now of individuals who can utilize
their intellectual abilities to create solutions to these problems.
Go ahead.
Uh, who was worse?
Uh, Twigs?
Go ahead, dude.
Uh, you can go ahead.
Go ahead.
Let's fuck.
Oh, yeah.
Uh, two asides.
JT, I don't know if it's like a, at, um, what do you call it?
A, uh, a trait of like high IQ or a mental, uh, something, but like, okay.
So doomer daddy is in the chat or whatever down below and you match his cadence and tone.
And it could be a thing that like, you have a certain either mental defect and a really
high IQ.
Yeah.
He's going to torture me.
He's going to torture me about this.
Um, just as an aside, really quick.
Uh, I'm totally like, Oh my God.
Like I do not have anything locked in and I don't really agree with the simulation thing.
Like, but like I said, I don't have anything locked in.
So it's totally fine.
Open-minded moron over here.
Um, but as an aside from the simulation thing, um, so I would like a second, I'd be totally
content just to have a second set of eyes and like super stoked.
If we could have a conversation with an actual, uh, extraterrestrial in regards to the storm
that we have coming here on earth.
And I see, uh, doomer left, probably trying to come back in and come up.
I'm not sure, but, um, because you said that I sound like him.
Go ahead.
A second set of eyes, a fresh pair of eyes on the storm that's coming, um, to earth and
the planets around us, you know, in the universe, quite frankly, likely, or at least that are
near the sheet, whatever the hell you believe.
Um, a second set of eyes, man.
Like I've had so many times at work where I cannot figure something out and just a fresh
pair of eyes.
It's like, Oh man, this is so simple.
Or I could have no clue really like familiarity with a really complex thing, but I'll just step
in the area and someone just needs a fresh pair of eyes.
And I'm like, Oh man, it's right there.
Um, you know, we could have, uh, on another planet, maybe for whatever reason, uh, they
just don't happen to have storms or wind on their planet.
Um, if they could connect with me, I could be like, Oh, you guys are all of a sudden going
to be having storms and wind.
Well, there's this thing called shelters and paint.
You can put paint on your house and it will protect your shelters and it will make it last
longer.
And there's a specific kind of roof that you can use.
Um, there could be, uh, very likely that, uh, uh, you know, it's going to be a
there could be maybe an extraterrestrial civilization that has been around through many of these
storms and they go, Oh my gosh, this is so simple.
Like, here's what you do.
And it seems insurmountable to us.
Right.
But it may be something that is just commonplace to a civilization that has lived through many
of these different storms.
Um, and I, I would just love to have a conversation with someone that had a fresh set of eyes that
if extraterrestrials do exist, I'd love to just have that fresh set of eyes and an open
conversation about that right there.
So here's the problem, right?
The problem is the, the core, the root message of almost everyone, except for Stephen Greer,
uh, and the love and light channel channeler people, right?
Is that, um, pretty much everyone else across the board, um, regardless of whether you believe
that we're at base level reality or not, right?
Uh, sees non-human intelligence is performing a series of, uh, experiments on us.
So there are people who will get into quibbling about, you know, good and evil, right?
And they'll say, well, it's, it's not angels and demons because, you know, they'll get into
these long moral arguments, but the essential nature of the interaction is not beneficial for
human beings.
And that's the core of the information that the government is disclosing.
And so when they get into like all the different Congress people and bureaucrats who have been
read into the, the data they have, the information they have, who then break down and start sobbing
at their desk, which is a common meme.
It is a common, um, it is a common story to be told, uh, about individuals read into disclosure.
They generally have a very strong negative reaction.
Jimmy Carter sobbed at the Oval Office desk, right?
And so that's what that is about, but regardless of whether you believe that we're at base level
reality, they're experimenting on us.
And it would be nice.
I'm sure to have this extra set of eyes, but that isn't what is available to us, right?
What is available to us is, um, uh, people who are, are trying to constantly dial up the
tension and the negativity amongst each other.
Right.
Because that's how, again, like that's what we do when we experiment, like we create simulations.
We don't create simulations that are placid.
We don't create unchanging harmonic environments.
That's not, you know, the purpose of that type of, uh, of that type of experiment.
The purpose of that type of experiment is to mess things up and see how they resolve.
Um, you could also look at it as a game.
It's not, but it's possible that there's a dual purpose or multiple purposes and that there
is some interaction, right?
Because regardless of how we explain it, the data indicates beings coming from a great distance,
uh, to here and possibly inhabiting avatars built here, right?
Um, so that could be beings from a far part of the galaxy, or it could be beings from outside
of the simulation coming in, but either way, they're assuming avatars.
And so if they're out in avatar form in our society, well, how do people behave when they
play video games?
You don't really write like, when's the last time you went into Grand Theft Auto and did
that so you could wander around and be a benevolent angel with all the NPCs, right?
It's the griefers is what I'm getting at.
It was like Minecraft griefers.
So that, that's really what they have to offer.
And that's, that's the problem with the disclosure, right?
Like the reason that there's this, um, resistance to disclosing the information is that ultimately
it's not positive information.
Like ultimately it's information that we're in a bad situation against beings that we can't
really challenge.
Go ahead, Twigs.
Um, yeah, just getting to your point about the, uh, ejecting the, uh, the old floppy disk and
tossing in another one for the full reversal.
No, it's, it's, if you, it's more, it's more natural than that.
Just the energy towards it, it just needs to, uh, it needs to reset real fast, but it's
not real, but yeah.
So the reason I, so no, just to point out is right.
So, so this is a space about disclosure in remote viewing.
And so what I'm talking about is actual remote viewing data.
Like, I'm not arguing against what you're saying.
What I'm saying is that we have remote viewers, uh, not directly associated with intuitive
underground to have looked into this subject and, um, multiple, uh, individuals see the
same thing, which is that, uh, during what we experience as a catastrophe, it is them.
Um, it's them putting the data away.
Basically it's them take, you know, downloading everything into a disc, taking out the disc,
putting it away and restarting the simulation again.
So whether that's metaphorical or not, that's the, that's the process that they see.
And so the, uh, magnetic pole shift, one of the issues that makes it so difficult to survive,
whether or not you're dealing with a physical pole shift, uh, is that you have a degaussing
effect.
Apparently, uh, according to the perceptual data, uh, uh, people will forget everything.
You'll have a large number of people with amnesia and you'll have a smaller subset of those people
who become violent, aggressive, and hostile, sort of almost like zombies.
So if the magnetic pole shift happened tomorrow, you'd have like 20% of the population acting
like zombies, you'd have 75 or during the flip that can be held.
That's the, that is the, the layer of consciousness and memory.
Yes.
That can be maintained.
Yeah.
So, um, uh, I don't know exactly, you know, what that, I can tell you the best of my understanding
with the, what those viewers saw.
Um, I can't necessarily break down the mechanics of it.
To me, it would be separating the, um, the biological beings from the soul, the animating, whatever,
that would be my guess, but it's just a guess.
But the, what they see is people during that event, the kill shot, the magnetic pole shift,
or whatever you want to call it.
Um, some of them just experiencing complete amnesia going forward from that point.
And some of them losing their minds and becoming crazy and violent and aggressive, but as a permanent condition.
And so if we imagined that there were advanced civilizations in the past on earth, and I'm not saying there are,
but that's a common theory.
If we imagine that was the case, then it wouldn't just be the, the cataclysm that caused the, the, the, the complete separation between the past knowledge and the present knowledge, right?
Like, so there'd be a civilization and they could be very advanced.
And the reason they don't, can't hold onto that knowledge is because a large percentage of the civilization, even the people who survive the cataclysm are left with no memory at all.
Like this started from scratch, like human beings immediately go back to living in caves.
Go ahead.
Uh, WTF.
Yeah.
Um, interesting kind of like conversation that I wanted to like, I don't know.
I just had thoughts and questions.
So, um, in regards to like altering and like, you know, having negative effects on the mind that are, you know, essentially knocking you out, knocking you down, giving you problems and potentially killing you or making you give me amnesia.
So it comes to mind, like say I was arguing with a spouse and I also missed sleep and I also had a headache and I also, uh, was like during that week, say I did a lot of drugs and drank a lot.
Uh, and then I had fear of, oh, I got a problem at work.
I'm going to lose my job.
Say I opened myself up one of those evenings prior to that, or that week, accidentally to something like a Ouija board.
It would be very uncommon in my opinion to have a negative dark experience, right?
Or during that week to walk into a room and forget why I'm there.
So we see like, you know, not in that time, there could be nothing going on in the earth.
Um, likely this pole shift has been, you know, starting to slowly occur for a long time, which is arguably true.
Um, but we can see how the mind can be so negatively brought down into a paralyzing state just by, um, we're not strengthening ourselves and we're weakening ourselves.
This kind of goes out to, I guess, JT, if you want to chime in.
Um, I don't know why the heck you would even want to live during this time and survive it.
It'd be so traumatizing, right?
But that's what we do.
We fight.
We live on.
Um, my question is, do you think that those that have strengthened themselves, like, um, through whatever destiny they've wound up to be just astonishing human beings with their mental strength and physical kind of, uh, synchronous, whatever you want to call it, just peace, whatever.
Do you think that some people will be unaffected during this pole shift because there'll be so strong?
Great, great, great question.
Great question.
So, uh, that I, I don't know if Morgan has, uh, data on that specifically.
Um, I, I can tell you like a bunch of disparate data.
I know one thing that they do have is, uh, they do have some data that is more religious in nature, right?
Um, they, to the best of my knowledge, they haven't put out that data in report form, but, um, we will be having, um, when we, when we appear on tailspin with Mav, if that happens, um, Dan Mann will be there.
Um, and this is sort of, he, he seems to be the one who has got that, like that specific data, like right, right in the forefront of his mind, the bond of the covenant, which is the 144,000 people, um, in revelations that aren't, uh, aren't, aren't touched by the disasters.
Um, historically, um, historically, there's some information that supports that idea.
The remote viewing data that I've seen, um, unrelated to, um, well, Morgan's data and technical remote viewers do see people who, who survived that.
Yes.
Um, who, who make it through the kill shot.
Uh, and that's what, uh, Ed Dames focused on a lot of his life and career on was getting the information out to people about how they could maximize their chances for, um, for surviving the kill shot.
Uh, other remote viewers also have information about that.
And it seems to me based on what I've seen that, uh, there's a, something based around coherence.
So you're talking about amazing people.
Um, if we were to go like crossing the, the technology of like, uh, mind, body technology with, with spiritual quote, quote, spiritual pursuits, the closest analogy would be coherence, meditation, heart, mind, coherence, meditation,
like either something out of the heart math Institute or online.
Um, I've been trying to track down exact details, to be honest with you.
The best I can tell you right now is online.
There are, um, like on YouTube, heart, mind coherence meditations, but it seems that, um, there, again, I have not seen, I've not seen any remote viewers look deeply into this subject.
This data came up in a couple of different, um, in a couple of different remote viewers.
Um, it seems as if, uh, the people who can get through and who, who are able to maintain their memories and their sanity, um, have a certain level of coherence.
And we think that might be heart mind coherence.
And I have my own impression is, is that it may be related to the, the function of the heart as a second brain, um, which there is a, as you probably know, there's neurological tissue attached to the heart, which serves as a, as a second brain.
And I think you would mention the energy Taurus, right?
So there's the, the heart energy Taurus as well as the Taurus of, of the energy of the earth.
So when you, so supposedly when you practice, um, heart, mind coherence meditation, um, that strengthens the Taurus, um, energy.
That's what the heart math Institute is all about.
Um, that comes from your, and I don't get anything from them.
I'm not a member of the heart math Institute.
This is just stuff I picked up along the way.
Um, so yeah, there's quite possibly techniques that you can use to increase your chances.
So the thing with that, I would say though, is, um, with two things, one, this is already happening.
No matter like whether this event occurs after we pass away of like natural life or not, right?
Like, like if this is in, in, in 20, in, in three years and in 30 years or in 300 years, right?
You can already see the effects.
You're talking about the physical effects on the magnetosphere.
That's true, but there are also effects on human beings, right?
Because there is a interaction, right?
We're not an isolated organism.
Like all organisms where we're connected in a sense to our technology.
Okay.
So there are already a decline in IQ.
There's already a decline in memory, right?
Um, we're already losing the, we're in a digital dark age, right?
So we're starting to lose this knowledge.
Like this is a, a process is not going to be like it hits one day.
And up until that day, life is normal.
Life hasn't been normal for a while, right?
So those, those, we're, we're in the midst of these changes right now.
And, uh, like the, the lockdowns and COVID and now with the Hantavirus and whatever else
is associated, um, with the Hantavirus and with the war, right?
Like there are going to be steps along the way.
And one of the things that we have to understand is if, if the governments of the world or a
government of the world, whatever are convinced that this is a future reality, right?
Or the elite or the, the rich, whatever, if they're convinced that this is a future reality, they're
going to make changes to, to human life now in order to, to increase their own personal relative advantage of surviving that crisis and emerging in the best possible position.
Right?
So some of the things that, that may not make sense at first about what's happening in the world do make sense.
If a significant number of important people believe that there will be less human beings in the future, right?
And less resources in the future, because if there are less resources in the future and you're a, somebody who's, you know, wealthy say, or powerful, or just somebody who's personally obsessed with their own survival, the, the way to do that is to make sure there are less people in the future.
To compete with you for those resources following this, this series of catastrophic events before we go back to them.
Hey, Morgan, you got anything you want to add to kill shot stuff to, I don't know, anything at this, at this time?
No, I don't think so.
No, that's good.
But, hey, if we're pausing here, why don't we just take a minute and say hello to everybody that's listening.
How's everybody doing?
Hope you're having a good weekend.
It was good before they started listening to our doom and gloom.
Look, see, it's not, it's doom and gloom for us because we've been exposed to it for a long time.
So, okay, here's the thing, right?
You can't just think in terms of what can I do to perfect myself as an individual that gives me the best chance of surviving and remaining me through some type of crisis or cataclysm like that.
Because, really, your first thing should be, how do I get to that point, right?
Like, people get old.
People get sick, right?
People get into accidents.
And if we live in a world that's preparing for some kind of crisis, right, more people are going to be passing away.
So, the first thing, if you're interested in, like, how can you survive that, is to think in terms of, well, how do I maximize my chances of making it to that point of time in the first place, right?
I started this whole thing out by saying, hey, if you're not taking apple pectin, why not take apple pectin if your doctor is all right with you taking apple pectin?
I'm not saying anything about it.
I'm just saying, like, I myself, that's what I think, right?
Like, I'm not giving medical advice to anyone.
I'm just saying, like, I think, why shouldn't I take apple pectin if my doctor is all right with me taking apple pectin, right?
An apple a day keeps the doctor away.
So, and maybe some of that is in the pectin.
I would like to go to unknown.
With, like, is it, what is it?
Is it a squid?
What is it exactly that you're, what is your avatar?
Your icon, whatever, your picture proof.
It's a golden apple that my daughter carved out with one of those little bore tools.
It was the first piece of art she shared with me.
Oh, that's awesome.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, go ahead.
What do you got?
Well, I was really interested in your simulation theory argument, right?
Because, like, the Fermi paradox, right?
The difficulty of civilizations actually developing and becoming spacefaring is almost impossible,
even, especially without faster-than-light travel, right?
But I'd like to posit that we're not necessarily in a simulation, but we may be monitored as an experiment from a different intelligent race that doesn't want to engage because it doesn't want to affect the results of their experiments.
But they would actually try and prevent cataclysmic kind of situations from occurring, especially, you know, solar system, like, major asteroid hitting us, right?
They could zap it out of existence before it even entered the solar system because they would want to continue their experiment, right?
Right, so the simulation theory for me isn't necessarily just, hey, we're stuck in a virtual world, but there may be an outside intelligent that's trying to study us.
But they would also cause chaos if they felt that we were entering a stagnation period to keep the experiment moving along as fast as possible.
So, yeah, so I can't tell you what to believe.
I can just tell you what the remote viewing data is and get into, like, if this was a different space, we'd get back into the historical data, which we cover in spaces, historical data, religious data, esoteric data, cultural data, and remote viewing data related to the subject.
We've run a number of spaces about that.
And I'm sure we'll run more in the future to be succinct about it, the remote viewing data clearly indicates that the periodic die-offs that human beings experienced are caused by non-human intelligence, directly caused by non-human intelligence for the purposes of reducing the population.
So the thought that the experiment involves them keeping people from dying is not supported by the remote viewing data, nor is it supported by the research into the subject of non-human intelligence and the phenomena in general.
I began this space, and as I do any UFO space, by saying the first thing anyone should read when they study ufology is the book The Gods of Eden by William Bramley, which discusses the historical connection between the phenomena and UFOs and events on planet Earth, much closer to what you would describe as causing chaos.
A simulation itself, I'm just going to tell you what we know, and people have to draw their own conclusion.
So what we know is mathematicians, so the people who originally posited the simulation theory, posited it based on the idea that it's a computer simulation.
We live in a computer simulation.
They speculated that the math would be around 50% chance that we were living in a computer simulation.
However, once we developed the capability of creating a simulation ourselves, once we had that technology, the chance would go up to like 99.99%, right?
Which is where Elon Musk gets his numbers from when he says it's, you know, one in billions that we're not in a simulation.
The technology is not there for a computer simulation, but that is not what we believe is occurring.
We believe there is a biotechnological simulation, a reality overlay that is related to something akin to a collective dream.
And we believe it's very similar to what you saw in the movie, The Matrix.
That's what the remote viewing data seems to suggest.
And that's what remote viewers see when they look into the subject is people being stuck in tubes.
The universe as we experience it being created from an experiment conducted on them directly in their brains, right?
So basically, networked neural tissue, right?
Creating the hardware with the added technological machine elements creating the, I don't know, whatever it is that's beamed into the people's mind.
The dream, right?
Like, there might be a computer that creates the dream, but the dream itself is being experienced in the minds of the individuals involved.
That's an idea that goes back to the beginning of religions and philosophies.
And it's a very ancient idea.
And it's ubiquitous through ancient culture.
It's what remote viewers see.
The math, to circle back to the math, right?
The math says that there's a 50% or said there was a 50% chance that we were in a simulation until the technology was developed to create a simulation.
There is a company and we started giving spaces on this.
Like, you know, I've been involved in this stuff for 30 years.
Morgan has been involved in this program, the Intuitive Underground Canon project using remote viewing to map reality for more than 10 years.
We began giving spaces before this information became public a little over a year ago.
And about a year ago now, it became public that there is a company in Australia called Cortical Labs.
And Cortical Labs manufactures computers that the hardware for the computer are human brain cells.
They use about 200,000 human brain cells.
So the brain in the computer itself is the size of a fly's brain, but it is constructed out of human brain cells.
It's a human brain organoid.
The boxes themselves look like pods from the Matrix, but crossed with like, oh, I don't know, crossed with like a CPAP machine.
The brain organoids are kept alive in a fluid, like brain fluid.
They're kept alive at the temperature.
They're fed glucose.
There is a ethical arguments made, like an ethical conundrum people having about this technology, because there's a question about whether it's possible they could be conscious or sentient.
The first thing that Cortical Labs did when they developed this technology was teach these organoids how to play Pong.
So the very first thing they ever experienced, because they have no sense perception, their only experience of anything beyond their own existence, however limited that might be, was originally the game Pong.
It was a simulation.
The second thing they taught these brain organoids to do is to play the game Doom, which is a simulated first-person shooter in hell, basically, set in hell.
So the organoids in the tubes play Pong, and they play Doom.
Hold on, let me finish.
They have now begun to wire them together.
They have begun building server farms, right, because data centers are a thing.
So Cortical Labs has built a data center in Melbourne and a data center in Singapore.
And those data centers are giant racks with these pods that look like CPAP machines, one after another after another set up on the rack, which is nearly identical to what remote viewers see when they look at the origin of our universe and the question about whether we live in a simulation.
These pods in these pods are wired together, and what they're creating is a cloud, a cloud of data, you know, we are able to access and program.
You could now, if you're a computer programmer and you won't have the money, and it's definitely expensive, I'm sure, you could now sign up to use a certain amount of the data space
in these data farms composed of these brain organoids made out of human brain cells that operate together in this cloud.
Now, that is, by every marker that we understand, the same principles that are involved in setting up the simulation.
That is basically a miniaturized version of the matrix with NEO, right?
Even though the brains themselves are only the size of a fly's brain, it serves as a proof of concept.
Now that they exist, and now that this is happening, now that we have created a biotechnological simulation involving human neuronal material,
the mathematical probability that we are living in a simulation vastly outstrips the probability that we are not.
We are maybe not where Elon Musk is saying, which is one in billions and billions and billions, but we're definitely one in millions, right?
So, I mean, for us, this question has been answered, but people will believe what they want to believe, right?
So, and everyone has the right to do that, but what we're here for is to share that information.
Now, today we're not talking about the simulation.
We're talking about disclosure.
What I'm positing is that is the ultimate disclosure, so that when they sat Jimmy Carter down, right, and said to him, as related by Representative Burchette to Joe Rogan, right,
like we are in an experiment conducted by aliens, and the aliens have created these institutions in order to keep us from, you know, from, you know, destroying ourselves or no longer, in my estimation, no longer having children and destroying the experiment before the experiment is done,
the missing piece to understand that, right, it may be what you're saying, and there are aliens on Mars or Mercury or something or on the moon that are operating on us.
And there are some room of viewers who argue that that's the case.
Courtney Brown and his institution, Farsight Prime, is one of them, right?
I believe Courtney is lying to people.
I believe he's being disingenuous, and that he knows the reality.
But another way of explaining that data and why everyone breaks down into sobbing fits, right, all these, you know, veteran, World War II veterans in the U.S. government broke down into sobbing fits at the desk when they found out the truth.
What was the simulation aspect of it was the simulation aspect of it, and not just the idea that, you know, we're facing an overwhelming force who secretly controls our governments and our lives, but the fact that, you know, from their perspective, it was hopeless because we are in a simulation.
So that's our perspective.
Go ahead.
Man, I think that's totally awesome.
Sorry, this is unknown.
Sorry if I'm speaking out of turn, but that simulation capability would also cause issues with remote viewers, right?
Because now we have simulated environments that they could start viewing, right?
And there's a definite lack of high bandwidth in viewing these sessions and actually validating them, right?
That's where there has to be so much study to, like, break out personal perspectives, right?
But I also think once we start simulating environments, remote viewing is like a remote viewer, but what if they tapped into a simulation that we started to run, right?
And obviously the simulations we would try to run the most would be about life-threatening situations that humanity would face that
we want to prevent, just from design theory on why you would even run a problematic simulation in place, right?
And I thought it was really important, your point, even emulated fly brains, where we started having them go into doom,
was a highly chaotic situation where they would have to essentially gain more intelligence to survive, right?
So chaotic situations actually lead to higher intelligence development rather than stability.
And that's why I think stability is not only in simulations, but...
I'm not hearing you right now.
Yeah, you're...
Sure.
So just, I don't know what's going on with your technology, but you're breaking up.
And I don't know how that works with X spaces.
And the reason I'm letting you know is not to be critical, but just so you know that we're not hearing a lot of what you have to say.
So I'm just going to go from the last bit of what we heard you...
Oh, he...
Okay, he's connecting.
So, look, that is what we would speculate, right?
I don't know if that's supported necessarily in the intuitive underground data.
That is supported in the data from other remote viewers.
Now, the thing about that is the best data, the core data, the frame, right?
That I would use to organize all the other data would be the intuitive underground canon project.
I would say that you need to start with, right, that organizational structure.
And then I would take the data from other remote viewers who are not part of intuitive underground because their data is isolated data.
Looking at one thing, no, it's not a systematic approach, right?
So I would take that and I would sort of, like, blocks or, you know, I would, or files, right?
I'd put that file with the similar topic that, you know, accession data from intuitive underground, right?
That's how I would organize things.
It comes up in conversations with me and Morgan, right?
Our personal conversations about, you know, explaining how the purpose of the reality overlay.
Not, not as remote viewing, but as two individuals who have an expertise on the subject at this point, right?
Having this conversation.
But it did come up in the other remote viewing data that the, the situation, what the, what the reality overlay, what you would call the simulation, what, what it is looking for is emergent properties, right?
It's come up with a number of remote viewers who looked into the subject, right?
They're looking for novel solutions.
And so what, what unknown was touching on is the Terrence McKenna novelty habit model of history, which is an accurate model of history.
And in my opinion, right?
So in this case, the, the simulation, the reality overlay, the, whatever, where we are, right?
Our world is designed to maximize suffering, right?
Now, this is what a Buddhist will tell you.
It's what a Hindu will tell you.
It's what early Christians would have told you.
What Jimmy Carter was told, what the, the, the, the secret of disclosure is that our organizations have been modified and, and, and quote created, but I don't think it's true.
I think they've modified, right?
That, that, that human organizations are modified to, to keep people from focusing, right?
Or to provide a psychological mechanism, a crutch to enable people to deal with the fact that we live in a world that is max, that, that is designed to maximize our suffering.
And the reason it's designed to maximize chaos and suffering and war and all that shit is that that is the way that you create the most emergent solutions, right?
Habit, normalcy, right?
A placid simulation wouldn't generate any, there wouldn't be any experiment there.
It wouldn't generate data that would be of any use to anyone.
So the, the, if we were living in a reality overlay, if we were living in a simulation, the way that we would know, would that be life would just keep getting more difficult.
And then whenever you solve the problem, it would create more problems, right?
Another thing we might predict is as one got older and one was nearing the end of one's ability to generate emergent solutions, we would experience more and more problems.
Physical problems, physical problems, financial problems, social problems, problems would just continue to multiply, right?
And they would also continue to multiply as we became more technologically advanced, because this would be a, an experiment that would have a completion date.
And the closer you get to the completion date, the more, right, you pressure you would want to put to create more data that you could harvest, right?
And so that would be what you would expect to see.
You would expect to see a strange world that became increasingly difficult to navigate, both as you got older as a person and as society started to end near that end point.
I, I don't think there's any question personally, but I understand that other people aren't comfortable with these ideas.
Right.
But to me, you know, now when I look around, that's exactly what I see.
So I think he's correct.
Right.
What he was saying was correct.
That is what we would expect to see.
That's what we would do when we create these simulations.
Right.
The, you know, the first one was Pong.
The second one was Doom.
Right.
And that's exactly what they did to us.
But we are in the situation of being stuck in the, in, in, in this, in that.
Right.
And so our, our focus is on trying to get information to people about how to better the situation.
I think that this is part of disclosure.
I really do.
I think that's the secret they're hiding.
And I think if you, you can see it easily.
If you look at like these leaked CIA files or the declassified CIA files about consciousness, about the holographic nature of reality.
Right.
They know.
They don't all know.
They also have a ton of remote viewers.
Right.
Who are returning the same data.
So they know.
You know, does everyone know?
No.
But I mean, the, the, the important people, the decision makers, they, they know this information.
And that is, I think what they're hiding for the disclosure thing.
It's not, you know, no one gives a shit if Martians are visiting the earth at this point.
We've been all psyoped out.
If a Martian landed, got out of the thing.
You know, walked around, drank a, a, a frap or a cup of coffee and then went back to Mars.
The whole world would breathe a sigh of relief.
Oh shit.
That wasn't that bad.
What the hell were they, you know, what were they making a big deal out of it for?
We wouldn't freak people out at all.
What freaks people out is that we are in a, in a powerless situation where we are the subjects of an experiment, a very highly unethical criminal experiment, but nothing we can do about it.
Go ahead, WTF.
Sorry, you had to wait.
No, it's all good.
I actually enjoyed waiting.
So much good stuff was said.
So I was looking for a fresh set of eyes earlier and we talked about that.
Right.
And then we went on to talk about how we might generate a fresh set of eyes with simulations.
Um, and you know, what's to say, like the people that made us a fresh set of eyes actually aren't a fresh set of eyes themselves for another simulation that's running.
Um, you know, every, it's the flavor of the week for me.
Like I, I'm a truther, like paranoid, schizophrenic truther, but I'm not actually schizophrenic.
I am paranoid.
So flavor of the week in regards to religion and God with me, because I'm so paranoid about everything.
Um, but if there was an ultimate one, super most powerful God, right?
One that started everything.
He, he would want to know if he already knew everything.
And if he already knew everything and there was nothing else to know, that's a limitation.
There's always something he'd want to be more because you're not infinite if you're not becoming more.
So therefore you'd run simulations, right?
And it could be that these simulations here on earth are definitely focused on catastrophe and all of these things.
That's where we are.
But it could be that these simulations are actually not all evil.
Maybe we got put in one by some nefarious people for sure.
Maybe I'm definitely done with that.
It looks like, I mean, come on, the doctors that I want to see, right?
I want to, like, I want to, I want to meet them and I want to ring their necks.
I don't necessarily just want a fresh set of eyes.
I'm going to be like, you know, what the hell is going on in the zoo we're living in?
Like, what the F?
But if I rewind a couple thousand years, like, I know you're talking about, and I don't disagree on how the scientific community is, like, leading the spearhead and figuring this all out, right?
But if we go back a couple thousand years, this is normal conversation.
I mean, it's only shocking now to the non-super enlightened, non-super intelligent scientists, like the mainstream scientists, super shocked by this, right?
Disrupts their whole lives.
They'd be shocked standing still in the streets, drooling out of their mouths, right?
But I don't necessarily agree.
Like, the religious people would just be like, oh, yeah, we're in a biological consciousness type of a simulation.
Like, that's no different than what we always talk.
So, shocking to maybe modern culture, but I don't think it'd be shocking if we hadn't gone down this path of diverting away from living in a consciousness type of a reality in the first place, which I don't think necessarily is all bad.
But I'm also not debating that we are in a bad one by some nefarious mother effers here, if that makes sense.
Yeah, I mean, look, the situation is what it is.
We're trying to, if it was just horror content, if it was just, you know, about freaking people out, if there were, you know, if it was a money-making grift or something, you know, it wouldn't have any interest for any of us, for me or Morgan or Dan.
So, there's no, you know, there's no money in it, there's no sensationalism in it, and there's no purpose in just freaking people out if there's no benefit to be gained.
But the Intuitive Underground material does cover information about how to achieve moksha, to escape this level, at least, of the reality overlay.
And the esoteric information contains similar, sometimes more elaborate, maybe off target, I don't know, we haven't checked it all out, right?
But we're compiling and we're having these discussions with people to try to compile and spread information about how to possibly make this situation better for the people who are involved, both in the present moment and as the crisis continues to build.
Leading up to whatever, however, the kill shot, whatever it is, the final sequence of events, right?
And, you know, a lot of people aren't going to make it to that series.
But that's not, again, that's not like sensationalism, that's not like doom and gloom, it's just reality.
Just reality that as time goes on, people get old, they get sick, and we're getting older and sicker faster now because of the shit that is going on.
You know, the toxins in our environment, the viruses we're exposed to, et cetera, et cetera, right?
Like, you can, no matter what your position is on one side or the other, because they divide everything, right?
They take truth, they break it into two pieces, they set it to people against each other, right?
Fighting over two pieces of the same truth, and then no one pays attention to that complete truth, the holistic truth, right?
So, you know, the COVID virus or whatever, because there are some people, oh, there are no viruses, there's no sun, there's no earth, it's a flat, who knows, right?
Whatever the fuck it is, cobra venom, whatever it is, it does long-term damage to people.
And the people who don't want to see that say, okay, you know, it's the vaccine that does long-term damage.
Well, newsflash, the vaccine does long-term damage to people, right?
That's just one example.
We don't like to focus on that because that puts us in a box with algorithms.
It also puts us in a box with the audience when we're trying to talk about, like, you know, the nature of reality and escaping this problem.
But it's, you find that everywhere, right?
We're, we're, we're, our quality of life and our health is being degraded.
It doesn't take a, you don't have to be a genius to suspect that that is something being done by someone intentionally.
It doesn't necessarily mean it has to be your own, quote, the elite.
It doesn't have to be, I mean, so look, the billionaires, right?
Like Epstein and, and, and Gates and whatever, this is like settled now.
They released the Epstein files for a couple of days, right?
Before they moved us on to the next thing.
And they had emails about how can we get rid of all the poor people, right?
So it's, it's no longer a conspiracy theory that there are elites in our, in our own society who want to reduce the number of people.
And I think that's one of the problems where we're having this, this, this global crisis.
We're building up to a, a, a war, right?
We're building up to like a, a war of the type we've never even imagined.
But in the lead up to that, like there is this stuff going on.
There's, there are, there are accidents that are happening.
There are refineries that are blowing up all over the place.
There are bridges that are collapsing.
There are, right, viruses that are spreading and that may not be, you know, more than likely it's not the people above us, but the people, can I ask a question real quick?
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, no.
One thing is the people above us don't, okay.
We live in a situation where bad things are being done to us by foreign powers and the people in our own society, they want it to happen.
Right.
They're not upset about it.
Now that's not, that's part of disclosure, right?
That's a different type of disclosure, but it falls into the same category.
Go ahead.
Hard to frame my comment because like everything is so, like every truth is easily, like even my own question, I see like how it's hollow.
So if we are, could we in a way, just in one way that may not be 100% truth, like the way I'm seeing it could be wrong, if we're all have biological sensors that may feed into some type of a mainframe that analyzes data, could it be that everything is kind of going on all at once?
And then you have to do.
And then you have this split and it's a purposeful split so that you have the maximum amount of people having the maximum amount of views.
We're not all seeing it one way.
We can all come and debate.
So we are crunching the numbers on everything, on mainstream health, on war, on science, on religion, on finances, on storms, on having children, on every single thing you can think of because you're getting near the end of the thing and they want to crunch all the numbers.
Yes, that's the point.
Yeah.
So peak observation is what you're talking about.
Peak observation.
And the period of peak observation was from November 14th, 15th, 2012 to approximately mid-February 2019, right?
And it's measurable in actual data of the amount of time people were spending on social media networks, the amount of time people were spending on smartphones, et cetera, peaked during that period of time.
So that was the period of time where the most people were focusing the most energy, intellectual energy, psychic energy, emotional energy, viewing and observing each other and all of these hypothetical problems and scenarios.
And now we've crossed that, right?
And shortly after we crossed that threshold, that's when the population started to decline in some measurable way, even if it was just a small decline that we could argue about how the extent of that actual decline.
But, yeah, so we've crossed that period of peak perception, right, peak observation, and we've moved into a period right now of almost like a secondary peak novelty, right?
Because peak novelty was at that point as well.
But this is more like of a wrapping it up, right?
This is Robert Heinlein's year of the jackpot scenario where he wrote a science fiction story about it was just one year and all of the crazy predictions came true in that one year.
Now, I'm not saying this will be a one-year process for us, but that's what's happening is like the – we are losing our – our mobility is being – is limited, right?
We're spending time in lockdowns where financially we're all – not all of us, but a lot of us are suffering financially.
Like, we're experiencing greater limitations in our lives, and the society as a whole is facing these, like, really novel challenges.
But that period is just – that you're talking about, that happened right there, 2012.
So we had a peak, and obviously, I wouldn't call it a valley now, but it's not – the peak has ended.
Are we going to go into another peak or no?
No.
So if we were to continue on, like, if this simulation were to run uninterrupted or reality overlay or using Terrence McKenna's strange attractor, if we were going to move historically away from the strange attractor, right?
So what would happen is we would move from greater novelty to greater habit over periods of time.
So basically, the course of the universe, as we imagine it, up until, you know, that 2012 to 2019 period is reversing right now, right?
So, like, things were getting weirder and weirder and weirder, and now they're getting weirder and weirder and weirder, like, with the news headlines.
But in our individual lives, that has started to reverse.
So we're still in a world that's constantly chaotic and crazy and weirder and weirder and weirder, but the beginning of the transition back to habit is occurring in our lives because of our limitation.
So financially, we're limited.
The amount of distance we can travel is limited.
I'll give you – I don't know where you live, right?
I'm not asking, like, for personal information, but I'm going to say, like, I live in Massachusetts.
I live in the greater Boston area.
In all of my life, you could wash your car at 10 o'clock at night.
You could get a coffee at 11 o'clock at night.
There were businesses open 24 hours.
There were people out in the streets.
Like, 24 hours a day, everything was busier.
And now there are fewer people anywhere on the street, right?
And this is something we've all noticed.
Like, they've eliminated overnight businesses pretty much entirely.
The coffee shop started closing at 11.
Then they started closing at 9.
Now they close at 7, right?
So the energy expenditure, the amount of time we spend outside of our houses interacting in novel ways is contracting for the average person,
even if we're still experiencing the increase in novelty on a collective level.
So that's how it can be both at the same time.
Like, the aggregate is beginning to return to habit.
And if we were to draw that out, if we were to be here for another, I don't know, 2,000 years, we'd be back in a Roman Empire scenario.
So there will be peaks and troughs.
The alternations between periods of habit and novelty will always continue.
But the trend now would be back towards, like, entropy.
The trend would be, like, the heat death of the universe.
Like, we're on that side right now where we're heading to the heat death of the universe.
Hypothetically, if it was going to last that long.
But why would you run that, right?
Why would you keep everything going that long?
Yeah, so that's the answer there.
But that's not from the IU data.
That's just from observation over the last 30 years.
And I think most of us have experienced those restrictions without really – I don't know.
Again, Massachusetts is not everywhere, right?
Like, in Texas, you can still go out and, like, everyone congregates at the gas stations, which are, like, malls, in the middle of the night.
And you can still do that in the middle of the night.
Like, so there are still places where that's possible.
But in general, the world is – of the average person is contracting.
That's going to be a big thing this year.
And that's – we run spaces on that.
That is, like, something everyone – you know, I tried talking about this last autumn.
And I predicted this particular period of time.
And I'm telling you, like, we're seeing it right now.
So, you know, what's going on with the airlines closing because of the fuel and now the viral – the spread of a virus on cruise ships or whatever.
They're going to try to move back to reducing air travel.
They're going to try to reduce cruise ships, right?
Like they wanted to do in 2020.
We're moving into a period of conserving resources, right?
For the people who inherit the earth after this crisis is what it is, right?
And we can either blow the resources, putting you on a cruise and Morgan on a plane, right?
And having me drive around town and blow that fuel, right?
We could create more electronic devices and doodads.
You know, everyone – the news cycle moves so quickly now that everyone forgets, like, we're experiencing problems producing computer chips.
We're experiencing problems producing computer RAM, right?
Like, even if there wasn't this fuel crisis and even if there wasn't this oncoming biological crisis and this war crisis, right, we would still experience, as this year went on, the reduction in the number of devices that were available on the market.
Like, so this is – it's like a frog boiling in a pot.
Like, we don't really realize how we as individuals, the average person, our lives are becoming more limited.
That's not the case for, like, you know, notable individuals who are still experiencing a period where their lives are basically unlimited.
But this isn't about that.
Go ahead, unknown.
So, honest question, right?
I mean, I'm an old-time listener of Art Bell and Major Ed Dames and lots of previous exposure.
But recently with remote viewing, has remote viewing actually provided evidence of humans on the moon or Mars?
Like, I know the old adage about, like, the original remote viewer indicating intelligence on Mars that we might wake up is kind of a risk.
But has remote viewing actually provided results of humans that were not on Earth?
So, Morgan is one of Ed Dames' protégés.
Not the only one, but one of them.
Trained with Ed Dames and had a strong relationship with him, and Ed would refer work to him.
So, I'm going to let him take that one.
Yeah, excuse me.
Okay, how about this?
There has been plenty of RV work over quite a long period of time that has indicated varying degrees of activity on both the moon and Mars
as far as what I personally, directly, have been involved in.
I've been tasked against the moon once.
Earth's moon once.
And my session work, you know what, when I'm done speaking, I will try and find it and I'll upload it to the pill here.
But anyways, yeah, I found, and bearing in mind, I looked at a very, very specific spot on the moon.
Okay, so that's not to say there wasn't stuff going on elsewhere, but I found evidence of a old, dilapidated, and abandoned structure.
And I had some indication that there was, like, I don't know, but, like, there was some sort of organic, maybe, bacteria or, you know, remnants of previous, you know, activities that had gone on there.
But there was some organic matter, in any case, left behind, but no current activity.
But again, that was at one particular place at one particular time.
And that's my personal direct experience with remote viewing on the moon.
Mars, I'm trying to think.
I don't think I've been tasked against Mars, personally.
Well, other people have.
And they've, you know, a number of different viewers at different points in time have looked at some of the anomalous areas on Mars.
You know, the face, the supposed pyramids.
And moving backwards in time, yeah, you know, they've pretty consistently reported tall, spindly, humanoid-like creatures living there in this society.
You know, apparently prior to Mars having undergone the loss of its atmosphere, you know, nominally one million years ago.
I don't know how exact or specific that is.
And it's...
Well, that's where the simulation thing gets in the way, right?
Because if we accept, also accept the simulation data, then time is wonky.
But that's, you know, that's another story for another space, right?
But that's where that comes from, like, nominally a million years, you see.
Could be.
But it could be something else.
What's interesting about that is there's this sort of understanding people have that the Martians left Mars and came to Earth and became the Nordics.
I'm not saying that's what happened.
I'm saying that's sort of an understanding that exists in the paranormal community.
That's the theory.
And from that perspective, right, the original Martians are very tall and spindly, like Morgan was saying, and have veins, very pale veins, very visible.
So, like, when you say, like, tall whites, right?
Like, they're not tall blondes.
There are, you know, people do record interacting with Nordics, but that's not what they really mean when they say tall whites.
They mean, like, white, white, chalky white, blue veins popping out of them.
And that's pretty consistent.
What I'm going to point out that's really interesting about that, right, Joe Rogan had a dream last year during the 3i Atlas situation.
That was very relevant, and it's actually what solidified my personal opinion about 3i Atlas and what was going on.
Morgan and I don't share that opinion, but my personal opinion, I was, I had not made a judgment.
I like to reserve judgment, but when Joe Rogan had that dream, that sort of put me over the edge, full disclosure.
And what's interesting about that is that that is what he, you know, he didn't have a dream that he was interacting with Nordics.
He had a dream that he was interacting with these tall, white, spindly people.
And that made a big difference, in my mind, because it makes a big difference.
It's like when you study Bigfoot, right?
Like, the people who really see Bigfoot see them with human faces.
And when you have someone who reports a Bigfoot sighting and they've got a gorilla's face, that person made it up.
It's very similar.
I took extreme notice of the fact that he had this dream that he said was more real than real.
And because of the spindly nature of the humans involved, because to the best of my knowledge, and this isn't coming from Morgan, but I think that, you know, from the sum of the remote viewing data, those spindly dudes or their descendants are probably in charge.
You know, if you believe in extraterrestrials, they're probably the extraterrestrials that are in charge in this area.
I'll leave it at that.
I'm sorry, Morgan.
I thought you were done, but if I cut you off, I apologize.
Sometimes I do that without even noticing, as you know, I'm boorish.
No, that's all I had to say.
Give me a sec.
I'm just about to post an image from that session I was talking about.
Sure.
Do you mind if unknown goes while you do that?
No, of course.
Okay.
Go ahead, unknown.
Man, Morgan, that's awesome to share, right?
But the targeting situation is really difficult, right?
Is there some way you could target, like, a future human presence outside of Earth, right?
Like, it would lead to some weird results, but I understand, like, targeting for that specific feedback might be hard, but that would be really valuable, right?
Because that would...
So, there's an answer to your question, right?
And so, that is, this is an intuitive undergrounds thing that I'm aware of.
It may be something in the future that they choose to target, right?
But other remote viewers.
So, this is, of all the speculative things you can talk about, of all the far-out things you can talk about,
the hardest one to achieve any feedback on is looking at other planets outside of the solar system, right?
Because that's, I mean, it could be, you know, we may never go there, right?
Well, yeah, yeah.
But could you target a human not on Earth somehow?
So, this is what I'm trying to tell you.
So, there are remote viewers who believe that they do.
We don't know if they're on target.
But there are remote viewers whose session data comes back and shows human beings on other planets.
Yes.
Outside of the solar system.
Absolutely.
I could...
The cryptid huntress is one.
She's actually...
I know the name kind of puts you off, but she's actually, in my opinion, a decent remote viewer.
The most prominent remote viewer on planet Earth today, in my opinion, is John Bivinanco.
And he and a guy named Rob Counts, who's from Massachusetts.
But that's about the best thing I can say about him.
He's not that bad, I guess.
But the show is great.
They put out a show called Metaphysical, where they use RV data to look at the far-out targets.
They look at Bigfoot and Dogman and Chinese Immortals and all kinds of stuff.
Rob and John have a pretty good grasp of history.
And sometimes they come up with things I don't know about.
So, I would put them...
I have a high estimation for their knowledge of paranormal history or the paranormal aspects of history.
John worked for the FBI after 9-11 as a remote viewer, right?
Now, there's a mixed baggage there.
He worked with Prue.
So, people have to make their own decisions, like how they're going to judge that.
But I have no reason to believe that he's not an excellent remote viewer.
And he's definitely...
You know, we talk about streaming services and people bring up a future forecasting group, right?
Well, Metaphysical has 400,000 or 500,000 people who are subscribed to that service.
They have a TV network.
It's Rise.TV.
And they do...
He does another show, Confessions of a Psychic Spy.
I have no problem being critical of remote viewers.
I'm not a remote viewer, so I don't have to worry about being critical of remote viewers.
And I have no problem, based on my 30 years of observation, of...
As Morgan will tell you, I have no problem talking shit, right?
Like, I'm from Massachusetts, as I said, like, the last...
I said it five times in the last three minutes.
I have no problem talking shit about people.
I have a very high opinion of John.
And I can't think of anyone who's more well-known globally in remote viewing than he is,
including the original viewers.
He has been to other planets, right?
And I believe he's seen people on other planets.
His explanation is that the human form is very common in the universe.
And it would make sense, to be completely honest with you.
Convergent evolution, or through panspermia, or, you know, or seeding populations.
We don't look at this as necessarily real, right?
And so there could be people all over the universe outside of the reality overlay.
I don't know.
But remote viewers do see that.
You can't...
There's no possible way to get feedback on it, to know whether they're on target.
There's just...
There's no possible way.
But there are remote viewers who see the secret space program.
There are remote viewers who see people sent out during the secret space program
who have rapidly multiplied in human colonies on other planets outside of the solar system.
I'm not saying it's true.
I'm not saying it's not true.
That would be the next ultimate part of disclosure,
if it came out that Gary McKinnon was right, and that we have a secret space program,
and that secret space program has been outside the solar system,
and there are human colonies on planets outside the solar system.
Even if this was...
You know, even though we're in a reality overlay, that's something that's possible, right?
It's possible in computer simulations that we create, video games and such,
where you go to the next level, or you look in a certain area, and more becomes available, right?
So like a new floor in the game, or a new part of the world.
The same principle might hold in the reality overlay.
Dan and Morgan would tend to believe that the reality overlay is vast, the size of a galaxy.
So if that's true, then it's more than likely true that there are other planets occupied by human beings,
if not other things as well.
But yeah, Cryptid Huntress, if you want to get someone who's a talented remote viewer,
who looks at things that are completely bonkers, apeshit, and completely unverifiable,
you would want to look at her first, and then go to Metaphysical with John Vivananco,
which is more...
still on the fringe, but more conservative.
And from there, you can find other people who are seeing these human colonies on these other planets.
And supposedly it's now, right?
But again, time and distance, and I mean, how would you even...
It would be confabulation to say that if someone were to say,
no, the rules of remote viewing are such that, you know,
we're seeing this other planet across the universe at this time.
I mean, they're just complete, complete confabulation, right?
Like, there would be how you imagine it would work,
but it would just be how one person imagines it works,
because we can't really say something like that.
I mean, if Morgan says something like that, then I'll cede to his judgment,
but I don't think anyone should say that, right?
Because who the fuck knows with those type of distances and relativity and...
I don't know.
So, yeah, I mean, that's out there,
but I don't think Intuitive Underground has that data.
Go ahead.
Oh, sorry, unknown.
I was just taking it for granted.
You were the only one with your hand up, so I was waiting for you to...
Yeah, I think Morgan's still on hold,
but I think it's also interesting that if we're part of an experiment,
even if we're part of a simulation, right,
there would be a desire to actually spread our evolutionary DNA, right?
Because that is the most valuable thing that exists on the planet to other sources.
So, I guess I'm not only obsessed with humans existing somewhere else,
but humans existing on the moon or Mars through their own experiences
to get there via human technology is almost as important
as identifying that humans occur outside Earth
is if they did it under their own power.
I'm familiar with remote viewing subjects.
So, it was Ingo, right?
Ingo and some of the original viewers with Stargate
saw humans on the moon as slaves
of Nordic-type beings.
So, at least that's what I've been led to believe
from what's available online and what I've seen in video format, right?
So, I've never sat in a room with them and asked them, like,
hey, is that really true?
But that's what all the information says, right?
Morgan saw the building.
I find what Morgan saw...
Other remote viewers have seen that building as well, I think,
or similar buildings.
Now, this is somewhere...
This is an area where we kind of disagree
because, you know, I'm kind of jumping the gun.
However, a lot of people don't realize this,
but the Chinese or the people of East Asia,
Central and East Asia,
Tibetans, Chinese,
is, like, who was really involved?
If we go back,
because we're talking about
anywhere from 2000 to 4000 BC.
But they have extensive legends
or historical records
of a mission to the moon, right?
And they built a building there.
And the guy even brought...
He brought 50 concubines up to the moon with them,
the general who went up to the moon.
They had a...
When we talk about the advanced civilizations in history,
we're looking at it from a Eurocentric point of view.
We're like,
there could have been advanced civilizations
12,000 years ago
in the United States of America
and in Spain,
and, you know,
and then they were destroyed.
That's Eurocentric, right?
Because when you look at it from an East Asian
or Southeast Asian standpoint,
the records of the advanced civilizations
are actually
4,000 years old, right?
Not 12,000 years old.
The records of the Hindu Vamanas,
the aircraft that Krishna and Ram
were flying around in,
they were using missiles
and weapons of mass destruction.
That was 4,000 years ago.
The Chinese themselves...
I never remember the date
because there were two or three separate stories
or legends.
When I was younger,
in books,
published alternative media books
that never made it to the internet,
they would have a picture
of a rock from the moon
that was stationed in front of a Tibetan temple.
And I think that temple
is probably long gone
because most of the temples were torn down.
The picture never made it to the internet,
and I could never find the book
or books
at the time
that it was in.
But it was...
I think that was 4,000 BC.
So it was anywhere between
2,000 and 4,000 BC.
The Chinese and Tibetans
record a trip to the moon
where they built
a large building
and lived up there.
And the guy had concubines
up there and everything.
And they were there for a while
and then they left.
And they described the moon accurately.
So it's not like
esoteric
groups in Europe
who would describe the planets
as having like lush vegetation.
Because there were like
sort of science fiction descriptions
of the moon
as having forests.
And the Chinese myth said
that was cold and barren.
It was like cold and rocky.
And you couldn't really live there.
You had to stay inside the building.
So I like to think
that that's what Morgan saw.
You know,
I don't think he agrees,
but I always like to think
wouldn't be cool
if he saw the palace of the moon.
And, you know,
I say palace of the moon sometimes.
I forget.
And I'm like,
I remember we were talking
about that palace of the moon.
He's like, no,
you were talking about
the palace of the moon.
And that was something
that came from you,
which you got to be exact, right?
Because I don't want to say,
yeah,
I don't want to like project stuff
onto his work
and end up like creating these lies.
So it is me
who said palace of the moon,
but that's,
it's an old Chinese story.
Morgan,
what's up, dude?
You still working on whatever?
He was getting some,
yeah.
I just posted the,
oh, cool sketch.
That's all.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
I'm trying to find it.
Okay.
Oh, it should be open.
Oh, is it?
Yeah, yeah.
The building you saw on the moon,
right?
Which I refer to as,
yeah, shit, dude.
That looks so close
to what Courtney,
Courtney's people see
with that central
color.
Yeah.
Oh, I,
yeah, I mean,
hey,
if you say so.
Yeah, no.
Well, I mean,
okay,
so close to what I've seen
that Courtney's people see
because everything's behind
a paywall, right?
But every once in a while,
they put one out
that isn't behind a paywall
or,
and,
okay,
so here's the thing.
Farsight,
Courtney Brown.
They have,
he has talented remote viewers
in my opinion.
He does.
They used to put out
some human news
and they were the best
at running
a monthly human news
prediction forecast
of any of the streaming services
that I've seen.
there's sort of
a narrative control issue.
Courtney has a very,
you know,
he wouldn't look at it this way,
right?
But from my perspective,
he has a very strong
concept for what's true
and what's not true
and I think that affects
what information gets through.
I believe that the streaming,
the subscription aspect of it,
you know,
like you could say,
oh,
it's to help pay for the cost.
I'm sure it is.
I mean,
there are costs,
right?
Like Morgan should have
a subscription service
to be honest
and to the underground
just to pay for the costs.
Courtney's subscription service
is only 10 bucks a month
or it used to be
only 10 bucks a month.
So you can criticize people
who charge $60,
$100 or more a month
for their remote viewing
subscription service
and I will agree
with you 100%.
The people who,
who criticize Courtney
is grifting
because he charges people
$10 a month.
That's asinine.
It's $10 a month.
There's all kinds
of information in there.
If you want to criticize
Courtney Brown,
you can't,
you should never call him
a grifter
because it's just nonsense.
Go ahead,
unknown.
Man,
the whole
Eastern reference,
right?
like, I was still shocked
to run into I Ching,
which is like a 6-bit
mathematical system
that Chinese adopted
like way previous
to the Apicus
that actually resulted
in like a 64-bit structure,
which is what we used
in development
of computer chips.
It's amazing.
So what differentiates
our society,
I think,
right?
This is my thought.
This isn't coming
from IU's data
or technical remote viewing,
although I,
you know,
I would love to see data
from technical remote viewers
on this subject.
I think what differentiates
our society
from like past societies
with elevated technology
is simply like mass production,
right?
Like,
so it's not that we're
a more technologically
advanced society
than humans probably
were in the past.
We're more geared
towards mass production.
Like,
I don't think that
there's ever been a society
with like bags of Doritos
and like home computing
and shit.
I think it was closer
to like what we're talking
about with the Russians
when we say,
like the Russians
had technology
on par with the United States
during the Cold War.
They just weren't good
at mass producing it.
And so I don't think,
like if you look
into the historical record
and also archaeological sites,
I don't think
you're going to find
like modern,
modern apartment buildings
and shit,
right?
I mean,
oh,
okay.
So the thing about that is,
right?
Like Rome had seven story
apartment buildings.
So,
I mean,
they were there
in the ancient world.
but what I'm saying
is you wouldn't find
the same type of life
that we have.
That doesn't mean
they didn't have
the technology.
It just wasn't applied
to the lives
of everyday people,
right?
Like they would fly
to the moon,
but they didn't necessarily
invent the automobile.
Go ahead.
Matt,
I find that really interesting
because I think
Russia actually
initially exceeded us
in mass production,
but not in complexity.
And it makes me think
of like the AK-47,
right?
Like larger round,
larger discrepancy
between parts.
You could throw it
in the mud,
pick it up,
it would still work.
But then like the US
developed the M-16,
which was so precise
and so contained,
supposedly you didn't
have to clean it,
which was kind of
like a big lie.
But the M-16
actually did have
higher accuracy
at range
where the AK-47
had mass distribution.
So like,
who cares if you can't
hit your target
with one shot
because they could
produce so many,
right?
There would be
10 of them
instead of one.
Yeah.
I mean,
the M-16 versus
AK-47 thing
is complicated
because one's
designed to wound
the other's
designed to kill.
But
yeah,
no,
they had
mass production,
right?
But they weren't,
they've never been good
at mass producing
the technology
they developed.
So
Russia still has
classified
scientific villages.
They have like,
I'm sure you know this,
right?
Because you seem
very knowledgeable.
So they have
towns
that are just scientists
like Eureka,
the television show,
but the Russian edition.
And they have them,
you know,
sort of scattered
throughout Russia
and they're very
technologically advanced,
the work they do.
but that never
translated to the,
to technologically
advanced consumer
products.
So
they were on par
with the U.S.
and the space program,
right?
Like until recently
we were launching,
you know,
we shelved the,
the space shuttles
and we were launching
everything in Russia
to go to our own
space stations.
But
they could have
with the technology
they had,
right?
They could have created
advanced,
technologically advanced
consumer products.
They just never did.
I mean,
they have consumer
products,
but it wasn't
the same thing.
You don't see,
right?
Personal computers
didn't come out
of Russia
and the computer
chips aren't made
in Russia
and
I can't really
think of any
major high-tech
export that the
Russians had,
historically speaking.
Yeah,
but they made
things.
But
what I'm talking
about is
more of a
principle than
you know,
than a
good.
It kind of
reminds me of
Sputnik,
right?
So they launched
the first
satellite,
but the
satellite they
launched just
transmitted a
default code that
that didn't
actually do
anything that
just sparked
paranoia,
which actually
triggered us
to have a
launch that
actually did
do something.
Right.
So with the
ancient people,
it was,
again,
it was just
sort of an
analogy,
but with the
ancient people
it would have
been more so
so that you
would have had
pre-C classes,
conserving
technology,
less than 10%
of the population,
and even they
would live in
fairly primitive
conditions,
but there would
still be
laboratories
where high
technology work
would be done,
right?
So like they
built,
there's evidence
of rocketry
and spacecraft
built in
Mesopotamia
and Mesoamerica
and Tibet
and China
not as
advanced in
India,
and actually the
Vamanas and
the Chinese
program historically
4,000 years
ago were
probably more
advanced than
what was going
on in
Mesopotamia.
We just know
about Mesopotamia
because it's
the cradle of
Western civilization
and Zechariah
Stichon and
Eric Von
Daniken,
right?
But that
doesn't mean
they didn't
live in
in a modern
industrialized
consumer society.
The two
aren't necessarily
the same.
Human beings
probably have
a certain
aptitude for
technology akin
to beavers
making dams.
It's just
part of our
nature and
it's probably
a function
of environmental
factors and
population
density that
result in
the beginning
of the
production of
technology and
the advance
of technology.
It's unlikely
we've ever had
the population
density that we
have now,
in my opinion.
But were
there flying
ships and
stuff?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Either that
or you just
had...
The other
option is you
had so many
fucking remote
viewers in
ancient India
and ancient
China.
They were
all remote
viewing today
and writing
it as myths
and legends.
Those would
be the two
options that I
would see.
Either they
had people
flying around
in airplanes
and blimps
and rockets
or they were
viewing people
flying around
in airplanes
and blimps
and rockets
today.
They do tell
the story of
people going
to the moon
though and
they do tell
the story of
people in
Vamanas
flying around
fighting wars.
We do have
a destroyed
civilization,
the Rappan
which
seemed to be
destroyed by
some kind
of event
akin to
weapons of
mass destruction
where you
have the
fused glass
in the desert
and shit
like that.
We have the
stories of
missiles being
used to do
that.
I think that's
probably on the
realm of remote
viewing.
I think it's
probably evidence
that it existed
at that time.
That's another
piece of
disclosure that
they could
possibly come
up with at
some point.
People should
be aware
that that did
happen.
That's part
of the
ancient
Atlanteans
or whoever
is supposedly
living under
the ground
or under
the ocean.
It's possible
they're surviving
from these
previous
civilizations.
People do
survive
the reboots.
It's just a
small number
of people.
It isn't
necessarily
good for
them because
we're trying
to get out
of here.
those people
are so
attached to
existence
that they
cling to
life and
they become
a negative
force.
We look at
them as
being a
negative
force
in our
development
as a
species
in a
civilization.
Go on.
Go ahead.
man, I
love the
Veimanis
because that
is kind
of like the
earliest word
that means
spacecraft.
But I
actually think
that we
were influenced
by a
non-local
society.
I don't know
if they were
humans or
not, but
there was an
advanced society
that actually
helped our
initial
development.
And I
think the
Veimanis
is one of
the oldest
historical
words that
actually means
spacecraft.
Yeah.
Okay, so
that looks
like we've
got JT's
first
disconnection
of the
night.
Dude, no,
no.
I was
talking with
the push
to talk.
Yeah, no
disconnections
yet tonight.
It's a normal
thing for them
to dump me.
But no, I'm
just sitting here
rambling away.
Yeah, Veimanis
is a weird
basically, if
they say they
work, I'm
sure they're
right.
It looks
kind of weird
to me because
anyone who's
seen it, it's
almost like a
flying castle,
but rounder,
like smoother,
but that's
sort of the
shape, almost
like a layer
cake when you
look at a
schematic for
Vamana.
There was a
company in the
90s that was
constructing
alloys,
supposedly, off
of alloys
found in
Vedic texts,
an Indian
company, and
selling them
to NASA.
When you
talk about
the Vamanas,
there are
Indian texts
describing the
construction of
the Vamanas.
different, again,
because of our
Eurocentric
perspective, when
we're looking at
these previous
advanced
civilizations, we
have all these
presuppositions that
aren't true,
right?
Or don't seem to
be true, where we
say, oh, all
evidence of these
previous civilizations
were wiped from the
face of the earth.
It's because we
don't pay attention
to Asian
civilizations.
They have books
where they talk
about, take this
metal and hammer
it like this and
bend it like that
and talking about
building spacecraft.
Have we built one?
I mean, I think it
would be crazy to
think that no one's
tried to build a
Vamana.
Certainly, there
have been stories
about them finding
Vamana's.
I don't know.
But I mean, they're
there.
It's consistent.
I've never doubted
it myself.
Other people seem
to, but they have
all kinds of
theories, right?
The people who
doubt that the
Indians have
Vamana's think
that everything is
angels and demons
or, I don't know.
Everyone has
their own
experience.
But I love that
word, right?
Because I see it
is like the
first expression
of a craft
that could
actually leave
Earth, right?
And it's
actually indicated
in some of our
oldest texts.
So the Chinese
have the same
thing.
The problem is
the language.
It's actually
there are fewer
scholars who study
ancient Chinese
than scholars
who study
Sanskrit and
the Chinese
government
restricts access
to those
documents.
Also, as you're
aware, there have
been these
historical purges,
right?
where they've
burned a lot
of documents.
The real
treasure trove
is probably
the libraries
they found
in Tibet.
Now, God
knows how
long those
are going
to exist.
And I say
that not to
be like
a Sinophobic,
but 2,400
temples, there's
like 70
left.
They just
tear them
down and
they tear
out the
foundations
and shit.
It's like
the temples
never even
existed.
As of right
now, there
is at least
one library
with 100,000
untranslated
old Tibetan
texts.
And it
seems that
the epicenter
for Asian
civilization at
that time
is more
what we would
call Tibet
than China.
There was
a period
of time
where Tibet
ruled over
China.
One Tibetan
empire ruled
China.
So we may
be talking
about Tibet
rather than
China.
And that
might be
one of the
reasons that
this campaign
to tear
down all
these monasteries
and get rid
of all their
records.
So we may
never know,
but there
may be
extensive
documents in
there.
The
Theosophical
Society.
The Theosophical
Society was
the last
major
clairvoyant
movement
before remote
viewing,
unless you
count Scientology.
Scientology is
in there too,
which is a
loaded conversation.
But prior to
that, it was
Theosophical
Society and
Anthosophical
Society.
Anyways,
The Theosophical
Society was
based on
the translation
of esoteric
Buddhist texts
by Westerners
who were
visiting
northern India
and Tibet
in the
mid-1800s.
So they
talk about
the simulation,
they talk
about a
lot of
details of
ancient history.
All of
that came
out of
these Buddhist
texts,
like the
ones that
are there
now.
So we
may very
well have
even older
information
about
Vamanas.
we don't
know,
right?
Where the
Harapan
civilization,
it seems
that,
I think we
talked about
this in
previous,
I don't
know why
I'm caught
in this
cycle of
always getting
into this,
but the
civilization that
ended up
becoming the
Vedic civilization
is from
Kazakhstan.
And I don't
know if there's
any evidence
of advanced
technology in
Kazakhstan.
So, but I
agree with
you, like
Vimana, it's
a fascinating
word, it's
subject, and
I think it's
unfortunate that
people who are
interested in
the paranormal
have such a
Eurocentric, in
our culture,
have such a
Eurocentric
perspective,
because it
really skews
everything,
right?
Like, we
were talking
about the
shape-changing
reptilian,
amphibian,
you know,
aliens that
people keep
seeing,
right?
Those are
part of
Vedic culture,
they're called
Nagas, and
they were
called dragons
in ancient
Chinese culture,
right?
So, like,
something that's
new to us,
that we're not
sure if it
exists or not,
is well
documented in
the Asian
sources.
It's that
type of
scenario.
I had to
just answer
something that
Sinan asked.
He asked
a couple of
questions,
questions that I
missed.
Yeah,
Rip Terrence
McKenna, me
too.
I agree
100%.
It's one of
the formative
influences on
my mind in
my life was
Terrence McKenna.
So, he
asked, what's
going on with
the light?
We've made a
ton of
spaces about
that.
We'll do
another one,
but it's
part of the
reality overlay.
it seems to
be something
involving, at
least from the
remote viewing
perspective and
the esoteric
perspective, it
seems to
involve the
recycling of
the individual
and the,
you know,
the, I don't
know what's
left, but
something is
left that then
goes on to
become the
next you, the
next incarnation,
but it
seems to be a
pretty, a
pretty destructive
process that
destroys the
identity of the
individual.
So, it
definitely is part
of the trap.
We just don't
know if, you
know, the
best way to
avoid it.
We don't know
if just by
avoiding the
evidence, the
RV evidence, and
we'll do another
space, because I'm
starting to wind
down, which is
why I'm starting
to, you know,
ramble.
I get really, I
get tired, and
I sound like a
moron.
Anyhow,
we're going to
get more into
it, the
different data
that, you
know, you
know what, we're
going to do
this when we do
Mav.
We're going to
do Tailspin, and
I want to do a
dual, I will
promote it as
one of our
spaces, and
we're going to
go back, and
go on there
with Dan, and
we're going to
talk about the
light, and
we're going to
talk about
what happens if
you don't go
into the
light, and
what, you
know, possibly,
what ways you
might possibly
avoid getting
recycled,
basically.
So, I'll
have to save
that for then,
and, uh,
oh, geez, what
was your other
question, dude?
You can see, like,
how burned out
I'm getting.
Um, the, uh,
cab, the
plating channeler,
I don't do
channeling.
um, this is
the, if you
ask me what
the danger is
in remote
viewing, um,
I don't
necessarily
think that
practicing
clairvoyance,
this is my
opinion, this is
not Morgan's
opinion, I
don't think
that, um,
training
yourself to
utilize your
clairvoyant
abilities makes
you more
susceptible to
being hijacked
by NHI, I
think that's
sort of a
superstitious way
of looking at
it.
Uh, what I
do think it's
possible that
people who
train themselves,
um, to, to,
you know, or, or
receive training to
be remote viewers
are more open to,
uh, what buddy,
our pal alien
protocols would
call, uh, uh,
multiple modalities.
I think that
remote viewing can
be, for some
people, a
gateway, just
like, you know,
smoking pot can
be a gateway
drug, they say,
right?
Like, remote
viewing can be a
gateway to
things like
channeling.
And I've seen
this with remote
viewers that I've
known, um,
not like, you
know, not
friends like
Morgan, but,
you know, just
people I've known
casually who, who
spend years
perfecting their
remote viewing
abilities, and
next thing you
know, they're
channeling, which
doesn't make any
sense, because
there's nothing
that you could
get from a
non-human
intelligence that
you can't get
from directly
remote viewing
the subject.
So, I don't
know whether
it's, like, a
pre-existing
personality trait
that leads them
down that path,
uh, but it
does happen,
and I think
that, um,
no, I don't
think there's
any possible
way to verify
the motives
of, uh, of
a non-human
intelligence that's
communicating with
you directly, if
that's what's
happening.
And, um,
history will
tell us that
they tend to
be deceptive.
um, folklore,
legends, myths,
whatever, they
all, all, uh,
identify the
non-human
intelligence as
being inherently
deceptive, um,
and not
necessarily, you
know, benevolent,
you know, not
interested in your
well-being.
Um, I don't see
that there would
be any difference
now.
Uh, in the past
there was, like,
sort of a
medieval or
folklore-ish, um,
uh, aesthetic
or, um,
perception
related to these
non-human
intelligence.
Now it's
technological.
Uh, I think it's
probably a facade
that they're putting
on, and I think
that, um, if,
you know, if we've
spent thousands of
years with warnings,
don't listen to
these things because
they're going to lie
to you and
manipulate you,
and then they,
you know, instead
of claiming to be
an elf, they claim
to be a Palladian.
I don't, I don't
think it's safe.
I don't think it's
a good idea, and I
don't mean to
disrespect Cab if
that's an important
person to you or,
or whatever, but,
um, I don't, uh,
I don't have
anything to do with
channeling or
channelers.
I just, too many
people get misled.
Too many people
seem to be deceived.
What I, what I
will point out is
that the data that
they get often
parallels,
the data that
remote viewers
get, uh, but
it's told from a
propagandist point
of view, right?
Like, um, there
is, uh, there
are these, there
are archons, the
archons, the
space decks, right?
Like, they're the
people who cause
the problem.
Um, they show
up historically, uh,
in, in, in
historical legend
and, in, in
myth as, as
gods, right?
Right.
And, um, there
are groups that
are channeled that
represent themselves
as being the
same, right?
Like the, the
council of nine of
Saturn, the
Ross, a famous
group that a lot
of people have
channeled.
And that's going
back to the very
beginning of like
remote, of remote
viewing and, and the
new age community, uh,
that was present at
that time, like
channeling this group
of individuals, their
information, very
similar to what
remote viewers get,
but from the
opposite perspective,
instead of it being
something malevolent
being done to
people, it's
something good being
done to people for
good reasons, et
cetera.
I think that that's
exactly what you
would expect if you
were dealing with
something propagandizing
itself, right?
Like the villain isn't
going to represent
themselves as a
villain.
They're going to
represent themselves as,
uh, as being in your
best interest.
I just don't trust it.
I don't, so I've never
investigated cab.
I would listen.
Um, so I will look it
up and I will listen,
but, uh, chances are,
uh, I am just going to
file that away as, as,
as something potentially
dangerous.
And it doesn't mean it
is dangerous, but
potentially dangerous.
And, uh, it's just not
for me, uh, but I will
look into it and let you
know personally what I
think.
Go ahead.
Unknown.
Man, the weird thing
for me about remote
viewing is the scientific
techniques that they
deploy to actually not
try and ask a direct
question that could be
influenced by a person's
experience, right?
So, uh, they may end up
providing photographs of
a location that they
specifically label with
unique identifier.
So it, it's significant
in space and time.
And that label has meaning,
but they don't even
necessarily have to have
that envelope with that
label in the same room as
the remote viewers, right?
like, uh, the disassociation
between the target.
Oh, no, you're a hundred
percent correct.
And in fact, uh, I very
seldom, uh, actually even
create a physical target
folder anymore.
I do it all on my computer.
It's all digital filing and
zero difference.
It's all the same.
But it's almost that
disassociation, right?
So you're almost dependent on
somebody else setting up a
target and not sharing it, but
giving you enough detail to
link to the data so that you
go into the remote viewing
session without any pre
preconceived motions that, that
that, that happens to trigger
the most reliable remote
viewing results.
Oh yeah, no.
And that's, that's standard
operating procedure, right?
Like the target examples that
you can see up in the, in the
nest here, I like, if I set
these targets up, so, okay,
well let's, let's look at
them specifically.
This one, the moon one, uh,
hang on five, nine, two,
one, three, eight, two,
five.
That wasn't set up by me.
I was a viewer.
I was only given the numbers
and I did my, I ran my
session work, uh, submitted
my session and then, uh, the
target was revealed to me.
Um, the other one, well,
anyways, the one that I, I
handed out to my guys, uh,
earlier, uh, in that
case, I set the target up,
but once again, I only
provided them with the
numbers.
They had no idea what those
numbers are associated with
and, and yeah, that's,
that's standard.
Uh, we would refer to that
as running blind and, uh,
it's not, you know, there's
a, there's some amount of
disagreement in the, in the
RV community about running.
So if the viewer knows
something about the target
ahead of time, that is
considered, you're not blind,
you're running front loaded.
No, you want to get into
the midi green.
Well, and there's some
people that can do that, but
like people without talent
that actually get trained in
remote viewing, right?
Front loading causes so many
errors.
It's almost laughable, right?
So it's not, it's not, but
there are individuals that
can get front loaded and
still actually have results,
but they are like the rare
talents.
Yes and no.
Um, I mean, it's not, it's
not quite so black and
white as that it's more a
case of, and, and I
personally, you know, and
this is where, this is where
there's, there's some
debate in the RV community
that, you know, some people
say any, any amount of
front loading, you know,
completely like invalidates
it as true remote viewing.
And I mean, I, I don't
quite agree with that
stance.
Um, my, my, my opinion on
the matter is, well, first
of all, there are varying
degrees of front loading.
Okay.
Um, if we, again, using
this, uh, this moon example
that I've, I've put up in
the nest, if I just gave
that, that entire thing to
them, you know, that
that's kind of a ridiculous
amount of front loading.
Um, now if the target is
let's say something, uh,
something specific about a
specific person and I just
say, you know, your target
is a person or your target
is allocation.
That is a kind of a, you
know, front loading, what
I'm saying is front loading
kind of runs on a bit of a
gradient.
Like it's not just yes or
no, it's, there's kind of
partial front loading, um,
full front loading.
Um, my stance on it is if,
you know, I, you know,
I, a fully trained and
experienced viewer should be
able to run front loaded, uh,
if necessary.
Um, now, you know, best
practice would dictate, you
know, you have a team of
trained and experienced
viewers all working the same
blind target.
That's kind of, that's,
that's kind of the top tier,
like in terms of reliability.
Um, but you know, again,
let's say maybe we face,
um, kind of the ultimate
test for that would be, let's
say you face like an
immediate or a relatively
immediate emergency or, or
something, you know, in your
personal life and, oh, okay,
well, guess what?
I don't have the time to run a
proper RV project.
So what do you do?
Well, I, I think a well
trained, well, a well-rounded
viewer could have confidence in
themselves that, okay, well, I'm
going to take this on.
I'm going to do my best, you
know, they, they might fail,
but, um, I, you know, I, I
think it's valuable to have that
level of, uh, training
experience and, and really just
confidence in your own
abilities.
Maybe kind of like an
argumentative comment, but
remote viewers could see what
happens, but by seeing what
happens and reinforcing the
belief in that reality, are they
actually collapsing the wave
function to encourage the
reality that they saw, uh, might
be one of the, the hidden
consequences of remote viewing?
That's possible.
I don't know if there's a
remote viewing position on it,
but that's, um, you could draw
that argument from, um, Rudolph
Steiner's argument about
clairvoyance, uh, and, and the
role that clairvoyance play is,
as, um, in constructing in the,
constructing the internal
architecture of the, um, of the,
uh, eighth sphere, which is
what they, what they called the
simulation.
Now, that having been said, um,
it's, it seems that, uh, the
original humans or whatever, the
original beings that, that
became us, um, the reason that
were one of the reasons that we
were cultivated for this
experiment, um, or these
experiments is because of our
intuitive nature.
So, um, it seems inherent in, in
the, um, in the universe.
Uh, we've done some, we've done
some talking about, uh, uh, Dean
Radden and the Institute for noetic
sciences, um, went looking for a
psychic gene.
And what they actually found was,
uh, a genetic sequence on the
seventh genome, a mutation that
is responsible for people who are
not psychic.
Um, they didn't explain it very
well.
And they went off in like a
political, um, an ideological
tangent, uh, after they discovered
that information.
And when I went back and looked at
it, I, I researched and by
research, I spent five minutes.
It took me five minutes.
It's not me.
It's just, if you ask the right
questions, the information is still
out there, although it's getting
more difficult to get it.
Right.
But it's all the, it's like
row viewing.
It's all the prompt, right.
Um, targeting statement.
So, uh, I looked into it and the
actual, or the function from in the
non-paranormal sense with the
non-paranormal perspective of the
function of that sequence of genes
is to suppress the expression of
endogenous retroviruses.
So what that would tend to suggest
is, um, at, at one point in time,
and again, this is from our
perspective, metaphorical, because
we're living in a collective dream,
right.
Um, from our perspective, but, um,
at one point in time, there was a
one or more retroviruses and those,
that period would mark sort of the
beginning of history in a real
sense.
So that would be like your, um,
Julian Jaynes, Genesian moment,
um, when consciousness shifted, uh,
also speculated from, from, you
know, on his part to be the same
time I, I speculate for everything,
which is, uh, two to 4,000 years
BC.
So that's when we seem to have
evidence of consciousness beginning
to shift.
It didn't really end until around
Shakespeare, like modern humans
didn't become modern humans until
Shakespeare, but that's, that's
another story for another day, uh,
around that time.
So, um, there are 40% of people
who, who don't have any psychic,
uh, capabilities and those are P or
don't have any measurable psychic
capabilities that, that, that have
been discovered in a lab.
And, um, those people have that gene
sequence, um, from that, right?
Like you could make the argument
then that the natural, and I'm
sorry that I'm, um, um, pemming
and hawing here, but like I said,
I, I subject to fits of, of mental
exhaustion and it's, it's difficult
to predict.
Sometimes it takes seven or eight
hours.
Sometimes it takes an hour.
Um, it's just, it's me.
Um, it's a known issue.
Um, so, uh, um, we all have
intuitive, uh, events throughout the
day or, um, very small intuitive
events throughout the day or most of
us do.
Um, most of us have had dreams that
have come to pass or some sort of,
you know, not what Morgan experiences
when he works a session, but
extrasensory perception on some
level.
Some people have a lot of natural
extrasensory perception, right?
So the argument there would be that,
uh, the remote viewer by looking at a
target collapses the wave function
and helps build or strengthen the
internal architecture of the, um, of the
reality overlay itself.
But everyone who has psychic ability
would be doing that to a small
extent.
So, um, 60% of the population will be
doing that to a degree when they were
having uncontrolled remote viewing.
Um, and I would argue that that could
be more problematic because at least
what Morgan is doing is, um,
he's highly specific, he's highly
trained, they're looking at, um, uh,
you know, specific targets that
generally include, uh, feedback.
Whereas when the rest of us have those
moments, it's possible that we're not
manifesting, cause I don't believe in,
in, in manifesting the way other
people do, but it's possible that
we're more directly contributing to
the, the chaos in the world around us,
like the, the suffering and the chaos
and the, cause that that's what our
nature does.
Like our, our natures predisposition
us to fixate on those subjects, right?
Like danger, um, for the reasons we've
talked about, like this whole, this
whole, um, space.
Uh, so if we're contributing to this
internal construction to a little, to a
small degree, it's probably in a more
negative sense than a trained remote
viewer is, they would be, there might
be a difference in magnitude, but
definitely as far as negativity is
concerned, like part of that remote
viewer training is eliminating that, or, or
trying to learn to eliminate that
negativity and, and those biases that
untrained people having remote viewing
experiences can't go ahead.
I, I, I, I kind of combat the possibility
that we actually have quantum functions in
our brain and we are actually existing in
time, but like an individual's wishes don't
necessarily carry matter, uh, but we've also
have evidence that if enough people are
contributing to like an experiment about a
random number generator, they can actually
influence the result that takes place in
the future.
So I, I, I, I'm trying to give you an
opportunity to close that as long as we
believe that there is some future, is it more
likely to happen?
No.
So because, yeah, no.
So look, I'll give you a great example.
Right.
Um, I just had a glass of water and that,
that's going to give me a couple minutes
of lucidity.
Um, cause dehydration is another like bad
habit that I get into.
Um, all right.
So, um, brainstorms, uh, brainstorm you're,
you're using, um, you know, it's a, an
idiom, uh, based on a metaphor, um, relating
what's going on in your mind to a storm in
the sky.
And so one of the things we've talked about
in other spaces is that if you follow this,
um, if you follow the, this collective
dream biotechnical reality overlay simulation
model, it's a lot of words, but it's to be
highly particular, right?
If you follow this, this model, then events
inside this collective dream that we're
having, that's where you get like archetypal
events and meeting in, in the collective
unconscious, uh, in addition to the actual
utility that those objects and experiences
has.
Um, so indigenous people have, uh, and hippies,
indigenous people and hippies, right?
Cause they used to do this at a lot of
festivals where they would do rain dances and,
uh, collective meditations, um, and a rain
dance, right?
Is a, is a form of meditation.
It's a, like you can actively meditate like
that type of dance is meditation.
So, um, they would have these collective
exercises in order to summon rain or
atmospheric events.
And oftentimes it seems we're successful.
Um, that is a collective programming of the
dream that we're in, but the, what's
happening is a collective programming of
the, the biological substrata, the actual
brains involved in creating this reality,
whether you look at it as a, as a
metaphor or not.
So by altering the dream, right, you're a
brain, uh, instead of a brainstorm being
based on the metaphor of the lightning that
we see in the sky, the lightning we see in
the sky is, is a, is a tangible manifestation
of an actual brainstorm, right?
So that's, that's how that works.
Like there are things about this dream that
are messages from ourselves to ourselves.
That's, that's what an archetype is or
messages from ourselves to others.
That's what an emergent archetype is.
That's what Jungian psychology is all about.
Um, and there are emergent archetypes that
are based on, um, uh, principles from the,
from, um, base reality that are, are, are
coming through.
And there are also events and occurrences
that occur in this dream that are related
to actions happening at base reality around
us.
So that's where we get into like the
similarity between abduction experiences where
someone can have a extremely, um, extremely
involved, uh, abduction experience while
they're basically dreaming or something like
a dream, right?
And it's called a psychological abduction or
it's called a spiritual abduction on the
astral plane.
But what may actually be happening is it may
be a memory of, or a, um, a perception of, uh, a
medical procedure occurring at base reality.
That that's another possibility.
So it's, it's the, the, the barrier isn't, um,
the barrier is porous the same way, uh, when
you dream the barrier between your waking and
sleeping conscious is conscious is porous.
So, uh, the dream and the, the, we dream
to, to give us, uh, a window into understanding
ourselves, right?
And, um, the dreaming isn't enough.
So as we, as this consciousness is emerging, it's
awakening, right?
So the real awakening isn't a political thing
about political parties.
It's, it's this, this, uh, coming to, to, to
understand ourselves as, as part of this
simulation, the simulated universe, this reality
overlay and what it tells us about ourselves
that we can't perceive.
So what Jung would call like the Unus Mundi, the
one world, you know, and, and the collective
unconscious is our way of, of, of receiving
information from the Unus Mundi, a way
of showing us something about ourselves that
we can't perceive because that part of
ourself is, is in a different realm, right?
It's a different world.
And that's, that's actually what he was
saying.
Um, so we've started to develop dreamlike
technologies.
Um, we, we started in caves, uh, where we
go into the caves, uh, and with the fire and,
and, and draw and create, um, a waking
dream.
And, uh, then we started taking psychedelics,
um, in order to, um, energize, uh, this, this
waking dream state to, um, to break the, the alpha
wave hold, right?
The, the rigid hold of waking reality and to the, the dream state of psychedelics, the dream
state of, of being in that cave, right?
That's the real, that's a closer, um, experience of reality than what we have on a waking level.
We use those technologies to sort of break up the, the resistance that creates waking what we, our
version of waking life.
And as time goes on, we build technology that is more dreamlike.
So right now the internet technology might not be very dreamlike to you, but if you think
about it from a historical, like looking at historical parallels, right, the closest thing to sitting
here and staring at your smartphone or your computer, probably in a dim room, uh, at least
it's nighttime here.
So the room is dim here, right?
Probably in a dim lit room is that, um, guy in the cave blitzed out on mushrooms painting
on the wall, right?
That's, that's, that's a, it's an archetypal foreshadowing of what we're experiencing right
now.
Now we've begun to build artificial intelligence and the artificial intelligence is again, uh,
an externalization of our own nature into something that we can see it from, uh, um,
from a third party point of view.
Like we can see this, this, this expression of, well, I mean, that's not conscious, but
this memory of consciousness that we can use to understand our own consciousness better.
And, and we've moved to the next step now, which is the constructing of an actual biotechnological
simulation, right?
So we've, we've actualized our own origin in a experiment in, in, in the world.
This is all that impetus to emerge into conscious of, of who and what we really are.
Um, and that's, you know, when you talk about like the ability that we have to, um, control
the dream.
Yeah, we do just like a lucid dreamer, right?
We collectively, we can become lucid and collectively we could change the dream.
Um, that's why we have these rigid institutions.
And one of the reasons we have wars and all this stuff, like the, the NHI messes with us
to keep us from that from happening.
Because we are of no use to them, um, if we achieve harmony and peace, uh, and there's no sense
in expanding the energy necessary to, to keep the simulation going.
Um, yeah, so we can imagine the future, but there's a wall, right?
We, we, we can make tangible changes, but we hit a wall at some point where the reboot
happens.
That, that's a hard wall because that's something done external to ourselves.
And when I say people, the, the, the viewers see the information being put on a disc of some
kind, that's actually what they say.
That's not a metaphor.
That's what they see.
Um, now am I saying it's, it's, they're not being influenced by a metaphorical process beyond
their control?
No, that's possible.
But that's, that's, what's the information, the consciousness, the, you know, everything that
we are now is, is filed away, um, before the next reset and the, the magnetic pole shift
is the degaussing.
It's the wiping of the, it's the reboot, right?
Just like rebooting your phone to factory settings is the, is what a magnetic pole shift is.
It's rebooting to factory setting.
Um, so yeah, we don't have that power, but what we do have, right?
The power that we do have is to, um, bring this, this information to other people, to, um,
find people who are rising in awareness and, um, approaching consciousness and share the
information with them so that we can hit a critical mass of people with a level of awareness
awareness and try to, um, try to, uh, create the best, um, the best, uh, network of support
the, the, the, and aggregate the best techniques to, um, allow the greatest number of people to
escape the oncoming, um, crisis, right?
Um, because it is possible.
Like there is, there is a, uh, life beyond the simulation, um, or something, or perhaps
a better way of putting it is an afterlife beyond the simulation.
So the point is, is, uh, escaping this bad dream that we're in and moving on to, um, whatever
we were intended to move on to before we got stuck, right?
So we're really, it's like lost the show, you know, at the end that it's, it all happened
when they were, you know, when they were leaving this world and entering the next, right?
We're, we're stuck in that, in that transition.
And, um, the goal is to try to try to help as many people as possible, have the ability
to, to, to, to make that transition, but it's only some where you're sort of looking for
those, those people.
Um, but in the meantime, you try to do the best for everyone that you can, and you try
to, um, diminish the role that you personally pay play in, in exposing other people to suffering.
And I'll tell you, like, I'm an animal lover.
Not many people are, I don't want to be critical.
More people are now than they were in the past, right?
Like the biological substrate, the neurological substrate upon which the simulation, the reality
overlay is based, right?
That encompasses everything that is.
So that's you and me and Morgan and Shane and Sal and Sennan and Melissa, especially Melissa
and bowl of noodles and Yagmer and even, even citizens.
I think that's citizens, Don, even citizens, Don would be included in that.
And, um, also cats and dogs and birds and mice and, and insects and trees.
And, um, you know, we get really into the aboriginal, like indigenous perspective on reality and the
consciousness of stones, right?
When they say, well, stones are conscious and you say, well, that can't possibly be true.
Well, it is, it is true if we're all, you know, part of this, this network, right?
That we're talking about.
If we're all part of a bio, um, technological, uh, simulation, then everything is us.
That doesn't mean we're all one person.
That's not that ultimate Gnostic mash of people, one, one, um, identity.
That means that we're separate identities networked together and being expressed in this dream,
right?
Like if it's part of the dream, it's part of you.
So, um, we would, uh, hopefully reduce the amount of suffering that we do.
That's also a step in, in, in, in getting out and escaping is try to make, try to make,
try to minimize the amount of harm and negativity, negative influence you have on others because,
um, those connections are more difficult to sever and are either something that motivates
us to stay in this situation, um, to go through another iteration of this bad dream or a thousand
or a million.
Um, it, it also, you know, uh, chains other people to the, right?
The resentments, the, um, the, the strong emotions that all, those are all the quote karma,
right?
That's, those are connections that are just, um, investing us in continuing this cycle.
And so we try to, to move beyond that.
I don't know.
I'm, uh, but the, the water gave me like, I remember I predicted two minutes of lucidity.
I think it gave me like two or three minutes of lucidity and now the psychological or the
mental, uh, exhaustion is hitting me again and I'm not making any sense.
So you better talk because I'm just recording myself babbling, but unknown, I was going to
go in depth, but Ingo Swann never saw an end to humanity and, and he's the person that
I think helped define remote viewing, but he was a prophet, but he helped shared his techniques
so that others could experience it.
So, um, yeah, I mean, that's like, okay.
So that's, there's a lot to unpack there as my brother would say, right?
So, uh, never saw an end to humanity, uh, in what sense are you talking about humanity
at base level?
Are you talking about humanity in the simulation?
Are you, um, talking about energy beings, physical beings, what, you know, as he's saying,
Ingo Swann never saw an end to the simulation.
I don't think Ingo Swann was ever tasked to look at the simulation.
Um, yeah.
Right, right.
But he never saw an end to human influence as far out as he looked, we were still
around and the lack of definition actually helps.
So what is as far out as he looked?
How far, how far did Ingo look to the best of your understanding?
See, you have to be tapped.
As a prophet, he never saw an end.
But that's not saying anything.
He never saw an end to what?
And so as a remote viewer, right?
Well, remote viewers are prognosticators can see what they look for.
So remote viewers are not efficient at all at seeing things they don't look for.
So what happens?
I'll give you an example.
Like an earthquake happens.
Every time an earthquake happens, they say, where were the remote viewers?
But they're actually more efficient at things that don't have a goal, that don't have a
timeframe.
Who, who, what?
I, that, that, that's one of the, the whole things about targeting with remote viewers is
that you actually try and have them have a target that is a physical representation without
them knowing anything about it whatsoever increases their accuracy.
You're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're confabulating that Ingo Swann was
targeted with looking outside the reality overlay, we're looking at the end of the reality overlay.
You're, you're, you're.
No, no, no, no, no, no, I, I'm, I'm trying to indicate that as much feedback that we have
from Ingo Swann, he never actually predicted an end of humanity.
Not that he was ever asked that specific question.
Right.
But, but the fact that he never saw an end, I think is important.
Well, and I, I appreciate that's important to you, but again, remote viewers see what they're
tasked to see.
Like you say to him, you know, uh, were you, first of all, I don't even know how that task
would be written.
Right.
But he would have to be tasked to look at the end of humanity in order to have a judgment
of whether there was an end of humanity.
Otherwise it's a personal opinion.
So, um, it's just not remote viewing.
That's all.
Well, no, he was actually tasked with celestial coordinates that happened far distant into the
future.
Yeah, I, I can't answer that.
Uh, you obviously have a strong, uh, pre-existent belief.
Um, remote viewers tend to be able to accurately view the future at this point, uh, uh, 12 to 18
months into the future.
Uh, beyond that, it's really difficult to find any feedback and it's sort of hit or miss.
Um, I don't know your, you're making general statements about what he was tasked to do.
I don't know specifically what he was tasked to, so I can't answer that.
Right.
So if you say like, no, no, Ingo was tasked to look at celestial events far in the future.
Like I, how can I answer that?
I don't know what the specific task was.
Right.
So you can't, um, contradict that, but like as an end saying, well, Ingo Swann didn't
see, um, didn't see the reset, didn't see the magnetic pole shift.
Like they all see the reset, the magnetic pole shift.
Right.
So, so let's kind of reverse that has a remote viewing session actually predicted the end
of humanity today.
I don't know about the end of humanity.
Right.
So we're looking at the kill shot.
That's the horizon that we're looking at.
Um, I don't think it's, so Morgan and I have ideas about how to increase the, um, the distance
in time, metaphorical distance in time that remote viewers can work accurately.
But, uh, to the best of my knowledge, no one's really looking beyond the kill shot because
that's the problem.
Right.
And that's the, the magnetic pole shift.
Uh, we do, uh, there's a great reduction people live.
Right.
So we're talking about rebooting it and you're talking about, are there people alive?
And I don't know what to tell you.
Um, are there conscious people alive in this world after the magnetic pole shift?
Yes.
Is it, is it a reboot?
Um, is it important that for you that the experiment goes on forever?
Obviously will the experiment go on forever?
No.
Um, but what does that mean?
I can't say, right.
Cause we're getting into now the nature of time.
And when you're in a reality overlay, when you're in a simulation, right?
Time works differently because we're, we're operating under compression, just like you would
in a, in a computer.
So the best information that I have, and this is not drawn from intuitive underground, it's drawn from another remote viewer.
It's the only remote viewer.
I know who's looked at the actual length of time outside of the simulation that has gone on during the period of the simulation is about four years.
Now, I don't know if that's true or not.
That's, it's simply the only remote viewer I know who's ever, uh, looked at that specific data and, and that is what they saw in the period of four years outside of base level reality.
According to this one person who may not have been on target and may not be the best room for you in the world, um, would be like the last 50,000 years or 5,000 years of human history, right.
Would have occurred during that four year window.
Um, so we're talking about things like time as if, as if we're talking about like something that's a set, uh, uh, a set factor, like that's not malleable, whatever.
But if you're saying like outside this reality over there that we're in, is it going to end last forever?
No, it's not.
Are there beings outside of the reality overlay?
Yeah.
Um, are they going to be there?
Yeah, they'll be there a long after we're gone.
Um, do human beings have soul, some sort of spiritual component that lasts?
Yeah, that, that's also the case.
That's, that's definitely something that they find in the data.
Um, will, in that sense, will human beings be around?
They're on forever.
Yes.
But, um, in this case, we've got, you know, 30 or 40 years.
What is it?
30 years now, 40 years.
I'm getting old.
That's why it's hard for me to say, right.
Of data.
We definitely have private industry data going back to 1996.
And in that data, there's a remarkable consistency.
Um, the, the question of like, will there be human beings alive in, in 50 years on this planet?
Yes.
The answer is yes.
Um, will there be a time when the human beings, this, this, um, reality overlay, this experiment
is over?
Yes.
But I, I can't tell you.
I would be confabulating if I told you what that date would be.
Um, is it, is it important to me?
No, I don't have that sense of importance.
Um, that this, that this situation continue.
And definitely, I don't see the situation as a good thing.
So what is important to you is, is the opposite of what's important to me.
Like it's important to you that this continues.
And it's important to me that it doesn't.
Right.
So, um, if, if you want to believe that that's the case and believe that that's the cases,
it's no, it's, it's, it's, it's not going to set me back at all.
You've heard the arguments.
Um, we can go into more detail, but it wouldn't matter.
You've made, you know, a decision based on those arguments and, and that fits your belief
system.
And that's fine.
That, that, that, that's more than okay.
Um, it's just not the, the one that, that we've made and we're looking for the people who
are looking for those answers.
Right.
We're, we're, we're not, this isn't a democracy, right?
We're not, we're not running a, we're not gathering as many people as possible and
coming to a consensus about what, how they want reality to go and, and how they want
reality to end.
We're trying to find the people who, who want the information about what's going on in reality,
who, who want to wake up and want to try to end their participation in this cycle.
So we're doing the same thing.
And the Hindus did the Buddhists did ancient Greeks actually did the same thing.
Um, Chan Botan tells me the Mesoamericans did it, but I, I, that's, if I told you, I know
for a fact that, that what he's saying is the same, what I'm saying, that'd be a confabulation.
Um, right.
Like this is the, the, the basic program.
This is the, the program that began the Zoroastrians originally had, there was a lot of changes
in Zoroastrianism, right.
But about 600 BC, um, it occurred to people that we were stuck in a, in a shitty situation
and we should start thinking about how to get out of that situation.
And those, that's who we're concerned with.
Right.
And, um, you know, if, if there, and there are, right, there are other people who, who
want to, um, think of things in terms of, of this whole situation lasting forever, you
know, I mean, more power to you.
It's, I tell you, like I'm 51 years old.
Right.
And if you asked me when I was 20, if I wanted life to go on forever, I would have said, yes.
If you told me now, like, what's the better alternative continuing to go through what you,
what I've gone through in my life over and over and over again, we're having an end at some
point.
Right.
Those of us, you know, at least those of us who hold this position, our position is it would
be better to have it end and to move on to the next thing, whatever that thing was, right.
Whatever the destiny of our spirit were then to keep fucking going through this shit over
and over and over again.
I don't understand personally why somebody who's older would want to continue to go through
this.
I do know that for some people it's about their kids.
Right.
And they really, they have such a strong emotional attachment to the children, which is natural.
I don't have children.
So that that's one difference.
And they don't want to imagine that the world ending when they, they, they, their children
might be alive or their children's children might be alive.
The best data that I've heard says that one in 10,000 people will be, will make it through
the magnetic pole shift with their memories and without losing their minds.
The people who don't obviously most people will be dead through the, the event of the people
survive, most of them, they're not going to be able to be able to be able to take care of
themselves.
The people who do have a memory are going to be facing 20% of the surviving population who
are extremely hostile and aggressive.
So, you know, you know, the chances are that most of them aren't going to, you know, live.
I mean, we're probably talking about less than 1% of the population.
I think that's safe when the, whatever this pole shift is happens.
Uh, they're going to revert back to like stone age type culture and it's the reboot, right?
That is the internal experience of the external reboot of the simulation.
And, um, they will do what we did in the past.
They'll climb up the ladder and they'll get to this point again.
And, and, uh, and the same thing will happen.
And sooner or later, um, it'll stop sooner or later, there'll be enough information from
it seems that, and I don't know what Morgan's, uh, I have a sense of his data.
We've talked about it.
I don't know everything.
So there could be something that I'm not aware of, but from other people's data, it seems
that, um, this experiment is kind of, um, left to its own devices.
It doesn't seem like we're highly monitored.
Um, and, and some people have likened it to sort of being forgotten.
Um, or like left on a shelf type thing.
And, uh, so that also might be a factor for how long the experiment goes.
Um, yeah, I don't know.
I mean, I, I'm, I'm, uh, you know, from a religious standpoint, we, we all know that all
the religions predict that the eventual destruction of the, of the whole thing, right?
Whether it's breath of Brahma or the Christian destruction of the, of the universe and the,
a new universe is constructed.
Um, I know Buddhists predict eventually the universe will, will die out.
I'm not sure.
I know there are different sects of Buddhists have different ideas about that.
And I would be confabulating.
I said, if I said that was my expertise, cause it's not.
Um, but I'm not really aware of any religious tradition or esoteric tradition that postulates
things will go on forever.
Um, I, I, if it brings you sauce and Ingo thought things will go on forever, it's great.
Um, I don't know if anyone agrees with him, but, uh, and I don't know if he was tasked,
but you know, whatever dude, if he, if he, that's what he saw, that's what he saw.
So we'll, we'll put him in the category when we, when we write out the spreadsheet, Ingo
will be in the, you know, Ingo Swan, uh, universe goes on forever.
Um, you'll never get out of this simulation.
You're just going to be fucking reborn forever.
Going through this shit, uh, you know, hemorrhoids and fucking cavities and, uh, broken heart
and, and working your balls off your entire life.
And you're just going to keep going and keep going forever.
Um, it seems pretty grim to me, but all right, look, I'm wrapping it up.
I got to go feed my cats, but I'll give you the last, uh, uh, how about, how about we,
we limit it to, to three to five minutes.
All right, go ahead.
Oh, and Morgan, you can, whatever you want to add.
Um, go ahead, unknown.
And then Morgan, let's do it.
I, I, I just don't understand why you think there's going to be such a dramatic die-off.
Um, and I'd love to get linked to that because you're referencing something I haven't been exposed to.
So I'm, I'm confused.
Yeah.
I mean, so we, we'd start with like, um, uh, a survey of human eschatology and all human eschatology talks about that die-off.
Um, a survey of, uh, uh, population sciences, you know, like the report from Iron Mountain, um, and, and similar documents constructed in the seventies that talk about that, uh, history of pole shifts that, uh, talk about that, the catastrophicism, which is the alleged scientific study of periodic catastrophes.
Um, and the remote viewing data is the kill shot is the most famous remote viewing target of all time.
And, um, to the best of my knowledge, and you're saying Ingo Swann didn't, uh, see it.
I don't know if that's true, to be honest, or if, if, if you're just, uh, misinterpreting the data, I don't know any remote viewers who haven't seen it.
Um, when they've looked into it, so I, whether it's myths, um, as profits, you kept saying as profits, uh, the only all profits I know, right.
And I, I spent a couple of years studying comparative eschatology.
So I'm relatively familiar with the subject.
Um, I don't know of any prophecies that don't include the mass die-off.
Um, and, uh, I know the remote viewing data.
That's what it suggests.
So when I look at data points, I'm not familiar with any data points that don't cover that.
And for you to wait to the end of this conversation and then say, you've never heard that you've never heard of the pole shift or the magnetic pole shift after we've had this conversation where you didn't indicate that it, it, it, it sounds like you're not operating in good faith to be completely honest.
Because I don't, if you haven't heard this information, there's something wrong with you, right?
Like everyone knows this stuff, right?
Like whether you watch movies, whether you've, right, this is an idea that people are familiar with.
So I don't know how you could make it to this point without knowing that people held that opinion.
That's a little odd, don't you think I would argue that any remote viewing about a kill shot would speak about possibilities where it would happen, not actually reflect reality.
Actually reflect reality that that's one of the vulnerabilities of remote viewing and targeting a specific scenario.
No, it's not.
That's a lie.
You either don't understand or you're being disingenuous.
So, uh, there are remote viewers who are off target.
All right.
But the probabilistic, uh, whatever nonsense is that's, that's false.
So, um, again, it's difficult to remote view the future.
Uh, that is not, uh, related to the fact that the future is in motion.
That's related to another, uh, other factors.
We run other spaces on this.
Um, this is an ideological issue that you're having right now.
Um, that you want to believe that's true, but it's not true.
And, um, yeah, I, I don't know what to tell you.
I, I, this is the, the, the large, single largest, most famous, um, prompt in, in the history of remote viewing is, uh, railing around the kill shot and the, um, the, the pole shift.
And, uh, it's just ingenious to say that, um, that you're not familiar with remote viewers talking about that.
If you're familiar with remote viewing, then you're familiar with that subject.
Um, I don't know.
I don't know what to say.
Uh, I, I can say that, um, you, you clearly have, uh, uh, a personal stake and investment in the idea that you're pushing, but, uh, you definitely are not operating in good faith.
I hope that you, um, you have a good night and I certainly hope for your sake that, uh, life and the future turns out the way that you're, uh, the way that you would like it to.
You know, they fucking wait until the end of the night to, to, to, to pull their troll shit.
Right.
So they, they go to this thing where they act like, oh, they're entertaining all the ideas and like, oh, wow, that's interesting.
Oh, that person said this.
And then they wait to like the last five minutes.
You say, oh, we're going to wrap it up.
Okay.
I've never heard this before.
We just talked about it for two hours, dude.
Oh, you never heard it before.
We just talked about it for two hours.
No, that's not what people say.
No, remote room can't work like that.
It was all fucking confabulated nonsense.
Confabulated nonsense.
Oh, they can't see this.
Okay.
So in one minute, he says, Ingo Swann as a prophet, which is fucking nonsense.
He wasn't a prophet.
This guy was a fucking asshole.
Ingo Swann is a prophet said the universe will never end.
And then he says, right.
Five minutes later, I don't know how they would target this disaster because they wouldn't be able to see in the future like that.
So which is it?
Did Ingo Swann say the universe never ends and therefore remote viewers can see that in the future?
Or is it impossible for remote viewers to see in the future?
It's all just bullshit, dude.
And it's like, why waste time?
The ideology, there's that compulsion people feel to propagandize others, right?
It's not like he's not entitled to his opinion, but this is a disclosure in technical remote viewing space.
It's not a fucking unknowns opinion about the distant future space, right?
And so, okay, say your piece, but they feel compelled to become like these diehard propagandists where they just won't let it go.
And then they start confabulating and lying and being disingenuous and contradicting themselves.
God, it's exhausting.
Why does it happen at the end of every fucking space?
Just go someplace else, man.
You know, take your fucking nonsense someplace else, troll.
All right, Morgan, what do you got?
Yeah, I mean, there's a tendency towards, like, once the main subject has been covered, people just do tend to derail things.
And I don't know why that is, but yeah, I mean, you know, that's all right.
I think everyone else here is more than familiar with Killshot and all of these ideas, so that's fine.
You know, as far as anything else?
No, I think I've said my piece.
Yeah, good space.
Thanks for having me on.
Yeah, cool.
Sorry for the dissipator at the end, but, you know, I wish they would just get it over with and go move on and not save it for the end of the space.
It's not even effective for them because no one listens to the space to the end anyhow.
Like, no, they're not getting the final word with anyone but me and you and Shane and Sal and Barkley Keduck and Sinan and Melissa and Andra.
Andra, welcome back.
Citizens Dawn, Yagmer, Disaree, Alucard, thank you all for coming and staying with us through the space.
And, yeah, I hope that we'll see you in future spaces.
And I'm going to, if anyone has anything to say, I'm going to end the space.
There'll be a 15-second, like, period of silence before the space ends.
Have a good night.